[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is the
incredible Ryan holiday Ryan holiday
returns to you made it weird I think
this is his third maybe his fourth time
I think I think it's his third he has a
new best-selling book out right now
which is called discipline is Destiny it
is incredible it is a best seller you
need to check it out also just all of
his work the obstacle is the way he goes
the enemy I mean he's got incredible
stuff courage is calling is another new
one his books are Life Changers you
gotta get into it he's incredible and
he's one of a kind and I'm so glad that
he is back on the podcast a couple
things to plug thanks first of all to
every everybody that came out all the
weirdos that came out to Largo last
night which was awesome recording this
on Monday thanks to everybody that came
out on Sunday I don't know why I'm
splitting hairs uh Adam Sandler was
there Judd apatel was there uh Mae
Martin was there and Christian Lee
Hudson was there an incredible show and
we do it every month the next one is on
November 3rd and that's a special one
it's to benefit Homeboy Industries a
cause very near and dear to so many
including myself so please go to
largo-la.com if you'd like to come to
the one on November 3rd if you do not
live in the LA area or you're not going
to be in the LA area I am on tour I'm
about to be on tour very exciting I'm
going to be in Toronto they tell me
Toronto not selling so good Toronto come
on Toronto please Toronto Toronto can
you hear me uh at the bloom Appel
theater on October 14th peanhomes.com
for tickets that's just a standalone ad
for Toronto because Toronto's hurting
Atlantic City New Jersey Boston Chicago
San Francisco Portland Seattle Atlanta
Charlotte and Washington D.C tickets to
all of those are available on
petehomes.com I'm so excited about this
hour I think it's super dupes fun and
super dupes fun e so I hope you can what
a stupid plug uh just go to pdoms.com
and come see me on the road please and
thank you and this episode is brought To
Us by our friends I'm so grateful to be
working these are Pym choose prepare
your mind original mood shoes and these
I they don't leave my side I have some
in my car obviously I have some in my
house in my office I have been swearing
by them because frankly I don't know why
this past week I've just been
overwhelmed like a little bit of a flood
of stress and anxiety and that's exactly
what Pym shoes are for first of all not
only do they taste incredible but they
are support natural support giving your
brain what it needs to cope with
overwhelm anxiety and stress they help
you manage those feelings and it's
wonderful when you're feeling worried
stressed out or as we like to say on we
made it weird well in I always say you
have a bee in your belly it's that
Restless anxiety thing you can't quite
land on yourself to mix a metaphor you
just chew to a these delicious natural
Citrus flavored no sugar added chews and
literally I can swear to this it's
changed my life in minutes you feel more
centered calm and in control in fact I
have quite a bit to do today including
record these intros I was feeling a
little overwhelmed and threw in a couple
Pym shoes about 30 minutes ago I didn't
even think I'd be doing these intros
today I don't think it's a coincidence
that these babies helped me get into
that workflow State and not feeling
overwhelmed literally the first time I
tried them I thought they were too good
to be true and I immediately bought some
from my mom and my brother uh just so
happy that anxiety and stress have a
natural non-addictive non-psychoactive
solution I like taking it at the start
of my day or at night to wind down or
sometimes like I did today in the middle
of my day to Help Me ease into my work
how do they work Pym shoes are comprised
of proven amino acid complexes and
adaptogens that help support your brain
and your body's ability to organically
support your ability to manage and
tolerate stress anxiety and overwhelm
these are specifically formulated amino
acids that Target your neurotransmitters
specifically the Gaba system a naturally
occurring neurotransmitter that helps
the body manage chronic stress supplying
your body with Gaba l-theanine and low
diola Pym is on a mission to help end
the stigma surrounding mental health and
make a better mood accessible to all and
for real it's changed my life for the
better and even better a percentage of
their profits one percent goes towards
mental health non-profits including
bring change to mind it's a gentle
effect of a natural way to give your
body the nutrition it needs to fight off
stress and I am happy to say that it
works and I'm so happy that they are
here to support the show so if you like
the show and want to support your mood
your feelings of overwhelm anxiety and
stress and support the show go to you
can
pym.com weird you will get a discount by
going to you can py am.com weird and uh
do your body a favor do your brain a
favor and show your support for this
podcast last but not least we're also
brought to you by our friends at on it
one of the oldest Original Pete's picks
is Alpha Brain I'm holding it here
because obviously I keep it here on my
desk Alpha Brain is Earth grown
ingredients it is not a stimulant it is
a supplement supplement is two two it's
not quite right it's like giving your
creativity fish food if your ideas are
fish Alpha Brain is like the fish food
you sprinkle on top helps with memory
helps with Focus helps me to dial in any
time I have to do something that
involves my brain if it's this podcast
if it's these intros that I'm recording
right now stand-up comedy writing acting
even just going on a date with Val and I
want a full access to my brain I will
take a few Alpha Brain 20 30 minutes
beforehand like I say it's not a
stimulant it's not like coffee it's not
an upper it just gives your brain the
Earth grown nutrition that it needs to
function at its best so if you're doing
something for your work or maybe for
your for your fun for your fun uh if it
involves your brain why not optimize
your brain I swear I've been taking
these for over six seven eight nine
years and I keep them in my car in the
office in my travel bag I panic if I
don't have them happy it doesn't give me
that like coffee feeling it just gives
me that feeling that I have what I need
to function brain wise at my highest so
it's an absolute Game Changer and you
can try it and show your support of this
podcast by going to on it onnit.com
weird we'll get 10 off everything you
see on that landing page go to onit.com
weird get some Alpha Brain support your
brain support this show and show your
support we really appreciate it in the
meantime everybody enjoy the incredible
Ryan holiday so honored that this guy is
my friend so honored that he came back
on the show and be sure to check out his
new book I want to make sure I get it
all you know what I'm just going to say
check out all of his books for real for
real they're incredible we talk a lot
about the discipline one you're gonna
love it get into it
Ryan how are you close those circles
dude on your watch close those circles
do you get that activity dude you didn't
run today not yet isn't that a big thing
for you yeah I like to do it in the
morning when my travel schedule is all
messed up I ran late I did something
super hard yesterday though what was
that well so I
a a friend and I bought this ghost town
in okay what in Near Death Valley
uh it's wait is it in Death Valley or
near it's above Death Valley called Near
Death Valley no no it's called Cerro
Gordo it looks near-death experience
Near Death Valley it looks down onto to
Death Valley and Mount Whitney and stuff
anyways I ran from the bottom of the the
town to the top which is
it was eight miles but it did it was um
it was in the m m it was you ran and
Eminem you get you get in at 3 500 feet
and then it ends at 8 500 feet so we've
been talking about doing it and I
decided to do it yesterday and I was not
prepared for it mentally or emotionally
or physically so it gets harder as you
go yeah well so it's basically it's a
that's a non-runner so it's harder so it
would be like eating a bucket of chicken
and then a pot roast I understand yeah
it uh if it went you you gain almost a
mile of elevation wow so but you're so
that means you're running almost
straight up one mile I hate this and the
and the air is Getting Thinner so it was
it was brutal why did you do that I
thought I decided I was going to do it
and then we were gonna film it and stuff
which we ended up doing and then uh
above anyways my body like quit like at
seven miles and then there was a mile
you did an almost Eminem I mean I did
the whole thing I'm just saying when I
buy like it was at seven miles you just
wanted it as it was done and then it was
like there's still and you know this
it's actually there's a kind of a
philosophical assistant you know like
when you're like I have this happens if
my wife's like I'll be home at two can
you watch the kids like mentally I'm
good up until like 201 and then like if
I've told myself like that's the end and
then she's like I need another 30
minutes that 30 minutes is like super
hard you are so right yeah yeah I
sometimes it goes the other not the
other way but sometimes if I know Val's
coming home at 2 30 yeah and I'm home
alone at two yeah most productive 30
minutes of my life yes you're under the
gun it's Indiana Jones work the boulders
not that Val's a boulder but I'm just
saying like yeah your free time is about
to get squashed I was very much under
the impression it was Seven Mile it was
seven ish miles not eight ish miles
brutal so the last mile was like that's
like what rips your heart out I yep I
completely understand so
you did do it how did you feel when you
completed it uh and then you have to
tell me about buying a ghost I felt very
good I felt very good that I
accomplished it I was very proud and
then I felt very terrible and I walked
into my room and I fell asleep for three
hours so yeah your body was like yeah it
was like all the alarm Bells were going
off yeah and uh yeah it was it was not
great but really like pain shaking
breathing yeah I think it was the
altitude and I mean it was just like you
know do you ever look at one of your
days and you're like that was not a
smart or responsible way to plan your
day I just had this yeah I'm I just had
my brain assessed for ADD and one of the
things they noticed that I'm bad with is
um shifting gears oh okay and it's one
of the reasons why if you put me in a
difficult thing but that's the only
thing I have to do today I thrive but if
they're like you're gonna go from this
and you're this kind of Pete then you're
this kind of Pete I won't do it and it's
like irresponsible actually like the
third thing is gonna suck yeah I'm two
things Max yes do you relate to that
well so yes yesterday I I took a 5 30
a.m flight from Austin to Las Vegas I
gave a talk in Las Vegas and I drove
from Las Vegas to Death Valley which
took five hours because the roads were
closed and then I got out of the car and
then I did that and I it did like it
wasn't until the end that it really I
was like that was too much that was more
than a reasonable person it was
committed to the run I would have been
like let's do this tomorrow yeah but you
did it I do that a lot I like I way over
commit and then only like in it am I
like
oh that's like too much well this that
was one of the chapters of your new book
that I thought was great was about rest
was it about the what is it the false
economy of overworking yeah that's
Steinbeck yeah yeah okay well I love
that and I'm a huge believer in that and
let me load you with this but then I
want you to talk about it I've noticed
the most productive day of the week I
try and take like a good old-fashioned
Sabbath like a Saturday yeah sure not a
true Sabbath like I'm not like not
walking over them whatever it is yeah I
just mean I put my phone in a drawer
which is the only way yes we all we both
know just saying don't look at it
doesn't work goes in a drawer but that
is the day that I'm jotting things on
like an envelope you know just like just
a million dollar sentence yeah it's not
about money I just mean like something
that is like oh I cracked it and I was
like that's you know it's
counterintuitive the most productive
thing you can do is to stop working what
would you talk a little bit I loved it
yeah I think it's like when you're
trying really hard you it's like off
when you try really hard at golf you're
worse at golf
and
so funny I think so like the harder you
push yourself you can mess up but yeah
the chapter in the book is interesting
is about Greg Popovich who invents this
thing in the NBA like 10 years ago which
you know this
is the best
when I read your book I'm like oh
there's an NBA like I don't know what
they're doing two recent like within the
last 10 to 12 years in the NBA they like
discovered that the three-point line was
worth more points than shots from the
two-point line like it's like obviously
always true and then like some math
genius in the front office was like hey
guys it's worth more points if we shoot
here than here and it's a revolution
well so so because it is just literally
when you were a kid the NBA was
primarily about getting the ball close
to the basket where a really tall person
would dunk it in yes and because they
were so tall they would make it most of
the time yeah
but then like if you've heard of Steph
Curry Steph Curry is short I am not
super tall and strong but he's very
accurate from the three-point line okay
and this revolutionizes the NBA because
even if you miss a higher percentage of
your three point shots they're still on
average worth more points than a higher
percentage from the two-point line yes
which is all second don't roll your eyes
like it's boring I thought that was very
interesting this is this is the tangent
to the the expectation that's a recent
invention in the end a game that's like
70 80 years old and now you see more
Larry Birds the whole game is around the
three-point line and even big big guys
who would typically get the bolo also
have to shoot three pointers and if
they're not good at it then they're not
as good as someone who can okay but the
other invention which Popovich Pioneers
is he realizes that players tend to get
tired towards the end of the season yeah
and that if you rest them they are
better in the playoffs can I just say
when I was listening to this chapter
yeah there was part of me that was like
sometimes it just gets a little too
close to like farmers and livestock do
you ever get that feeling no where
they're like well if they put out the
fields but you've got to rest there's
not a lot of love like it seems they're
like numbers on a balance sheet exactly
but they're they're talking about a
human person and they're like if we rest
him like but but it's it's almost that
he was like oh we like we just treat the
these are thoroughbred race horses and
we're treating them like they're not and
and so he makes this decision uh in a
nationally televised game against the
Heat which is their Rivals he sends the
players home and he's like you're you
you played in the Olympics last year you
we made it all the way to the like very
deep in the playoffs last year and
you're like in your 15th season like
this is too much this game doesn't
matter what matters is are you ready uh
during the playoffs and so we're gonna
rest you and he calls this load
management can I ask a question yeah
Sports question it's already a foregone
conclusion that they're going to be in
the playoffs no but the game is 82
Seasons long so one if you're right like
obviously they matter and they matter
closer towards the postseason when it's
like yes the it's it's more clear how
many games will separate you and what
place you'll make but he basically he
goes like hey this it's not worth it I
talked to this one on my podcast I
talked to this one um edit that out
I talked to this mountain bike racer uh
her name was Kate Courtney and her coach
told her once she's like she's sort of
like me as works too hard in practice
she's like do you want to be fast now or
fast later oh wow and so that's what
Popovich is making the trade-offs do you
want to be good later or do you want to
be good for a long time or do you want
to hurt yourself now yeah and and so he
rests them the funny part of the story
is that he thinks he's sending them home
on the team plane but there's a problem
with the team plane and so he ends up uh
having to book them a Southwest flight
uh and so they're on with the three
superstars who are seven feet tall are
scrunched and so that was also the
reason they ended up getting in so much
trouble for it is that everyone knew it
was coming because they'd been seen on
like instead of flying they're just
right they're on a Southwest flight
towards San Antonio like the day of the
game and that was part of that's part of
how it went but even pre-twitter people
could that rumor could spread just on a
rotary phone this was 2012. so this was
oh it was okay but that's that's my
point I can't believe it broke that late
this wasn't like 1982. I've been
picturing winning time this whole time
no no this is very recent uh Steph Curry
is a recent player everybody
there are there may still be one or two
players from that team that have not
retired like this okay
um I mean like one of the players Manu
Ginobili who's awesome he would actually
love you really yes why do you say that
he's just really funny okay okay anyways
he um he was inducted in the Hall of
Fame like this week so like but so
that's how recent it is like and but the
idea that even the NBA more recently uh
like in the last three or four years as
a league not even like a team trying to
get Advantage realize that that
back-to-back games are really bad for
the players yeah so like they have to
get on that me like uh and Baxter Holmes
wrote this piece in in ESPN about it
about uh like sleep like the NBA has
only recently started to think about
like how much sleep are you getting and
so all of these things which seem very
basic are in fact not basic at all and
even at the elite level they're not
basic and that's insane today yes
because my whole life I think you're the
same way one of the things we relate
over is looking to get that Coca-Cola
recipe just right yeah and I'm looking
at things like like shifting gears like
I don't know now I'm adding that to my
recipe don't shift gears more than twice
in a day because if I have my Largo show
and I had a podcast and one more thing
the Largo Show's gonna not be as good it
sucks I need that rest and that relief
of Burden but sleep is such an obsession
of mine it's like if I have a great day
I'm looking at not just last night's
sleep but a few nights before I can't
believe the NBA wasn't having everybody
wear uh were they called whoops and
stuff yeah well it's like what are you
optimizing for if you're optimizing for
having the most efficient schedule
you're not thinking about the people who
have to who are like the things you're
moving around yes right and so that it
was it you should be seen like when they
talk to their parents yeah you really
should yeah you should go like Jordan
like remember how Jordan plays better
when he's mad yeah you should be like
this guy plays better Steph Curry plays
better if he doesn't call his mom on
Sunday or if he does and it sounds like
a bit well this is I'm funnier if I'm
angry because I just had a bad call home
well all the all the teams now have
sports psychology they've also yeah
um
because they're like we pay this person
40 million dollars a year and then we're
just like go do your thing do this the
same with the acting sorry I didn't mean
to interrupt but I'm just like actors
coming in hungover not still drunk not
sleeping and you're just like you want
to think hey we're giving let's say it's
a million dollars for a movie we want to
think that means you're going to get
eight hours or at least something but
you're like no I'm not saying we should
Marshal this but maybe not everybody
knows that those things matter no they
don't or there's just a million like
like for the pen like I know all these
things and then when the pandemic
happened it took a bunch of stuff away
pandemic yeah it was suddenly like I'm
kidding oh this there this is what those
opportunity costs look like
because I'm not doing stuff
and now my other stuff is better so is
it in their contract now that it's like
we we want access to your sleep data uh
maybe you see guys that want to stay out
all night give their whoop to someone
else now like that you wear heart
monitors in practice and they can track
like who's working hard who's working
too hard they can try to catch people
like before injuries and stuff
especially in college sports where they
have more like control over the players
um the problem is these are also like
grown adults who have sacrificed so hard
to get where they are you'd think oh of
course they want to sacrifice more but
there's also a part of you that's like
but I'm here 22 and I made 10 million
last year yes I want to I don't want to
be a monk what is the it's like success
actually starts to become the impediment
this is something did you watch The
Donut King documentary no I was very
interested that I I've told this a
million times and I'm pretty sure it's
Cambodian uh immigrants started all the
donut places out here in LA and I found
this as fascinating because the reason
why they started losing after one
generation of really kicking ass making
millions and millions of dollars was
because when you make millions and
millions of dollars you send your kids
to college and kids that go to college
don't want to work with their parents
don't a place for free yeah which is how
they kept their overhead so low and why
they made millions of dollars so it's
like success ends so here they are you
make all these sacrifices now you're 22
and I give you 10 million dollars it's
like the worst thing I could do yeah
yeah so the absolute worst Choice well
yeah Tennessee Williams calls it the
catastrophe of success and and so yeah
you arrive you do your thing and now
this is what I kind of been talking
about the book is like before you had to
have discipline because if you're not
disciplined you can't like get to where
you wanted to go but now you're here and
now you can do whatever you want and now
it's like a different kind of discipline
is required that occurred to me reading
your book
it reminded me of another book the title
is escaping me but it's something like
you made it now what like what do you do
after you reach a cruising altitude yeah
people lose that's why not to bring up
my work but like crashing was an easy
easily compelling show because it's
about making it but what's actually
pretty interesting but less it's less
easy to describe to people is what do
you do when you've like made it and now
you're tempted to [__] off become an
alcoholic phone it in like you see this
we see this with artists and athletes
all the time and I actually think that's
the harder thing because like the other
there is a version where
you solve that problem by just never
accepting that you've made it
right so like this is what you see you
remain perpetually hungry all like that
Michael the reason Michael Jordan is
making himself Matt is mad is so he has
something to prove uh and he wants to
play like he's still trying to prove
yeah which is what he was doing like I
can do this I can do this now he's doing
it now he has to be mad at yeah somebody
just to stay that way yeah and that
works but it's not exactly a recipe for
being like I don't even want to say a
good person but like a happy person like
it's not it's very costly to everyone
around you and also to sort of enjoying
that success so to me the heart like can
you be good at what you do and be like
find a reason to be good with it without
using the sort of artificial fuel of
like oh I'm gonna pretend I didn't make
it yeah I'm still angry or whatever like
it's a cheap fuel yes it's not a clean
burning gas that's right it affects the
people around you and all that stuff
yeah I actually see people or I'd love
to hear what you think about this like
sometimes times when I get low like
let's say something goes wrong then I do
catch myself having more naturally
occurring motivation sure and it's
because I did something and I felt like
a fraud I just I did a show in Vegas it
didn't go my way it was a corporate show
yeah those are awful yeah you typically
difficult shows and it didn't go well
and then the next show you're like
you're really fighting for it then I
started to go like at really really high
levels Bill Gates Zuckerberg whoever are
they manufacturing are they failing on
purpose like sometimes I wonder are they
investing in something knowing they're
going to fail because they want to get
mad are they jordaning it that way yeah
in sports they they'll make something up
so it'd be like Okay Kevin Durant wins
with golden state and then then like
commentator said well you weren't the
bus driver like you weren't it wasn't it
didn't count because you're with other
people wow and then so like he has he
ends up going to another team and it
hasn't gone well for a lot of reasons uh
but but the point is like the idea yeah
that like you're not a success because
you were successful with other
successful people is exactly the kind of
like Insidious evolutionary like ego
driven lie that we tell ourselves and
other people tell us so we're not happy
and content and just like good right
there has to be like a reason that it's
not enough but that's why it's sort of
insanity I don't know if you know that I
love a woman named Byron Katie who has
something called the work does that
sound familiar with you Bill she does
this whole thing where you would take
into question your beliefs right yeah
and I'm almost done I know people have
heard me talk about this too much but if
you go like I need another championship
yeah she would say is that true yes and
like what's behind it like I need
another championship to be happy is that
true she could like help settle them
down and go dude you have all of your
needs met a family that loves you a
house in Bora Bora or whatever the [__]
it is just like just be happy but it
would break
everything in the west like we need
these myths but and that's what I mean
so like let's say she worked and I do
that with myself like so let's say you
get there and you're like no I actually
don't need another championship yeah can
you still
be good at basketball without need like
can you get to a place where you're
doing what you want because you like
doing it or it's pure and it's part of
who you are and it's your calling Etc
and not this is this is the the drama
that's surrounding Tom Brady to go back
to sports right now he uh he leaves New
England which is like the most grueling
place you could possibly play sports
news to me yeah he go he goes to Tampa
Bay and one of the one of the
speculations is he goes there
um because he wants to continue playing
football but he wants to his wife wants
him to play it in a more like
sustainable environment where he's not
like a miserable mess all the time where
he's not like grinding himself so he
goes and he wins there it proves
everyone wrong wins the most uh Super
Bowl rings that anyone's ever won and
then retire he has a really good season
last year retires at the end of it or
speculate he's going to retire he
retires he makes it like 20 days and
then he unretires and he's coming back
this year and now again I don't know him
so this I'm just I'm using this as a
general metaphor rather than speculating
on a certain person's personal life but
the argument the speculation is that she
his wife is leaving him uh over this
that she the agreement was he would
retire she had been like sort of stay at
home with the kids this whole time he's
like you better retire because I need
you around yeah and plus football is
like a super dangerous game and like
it's like boxing like you should leave
before it's too late yes and and so that
that to me is like that's can you
so if you can keep doing it and it
doesn't tear your family apart then it's
probably a good then you should keep
doing it but like if you if you would
trade your family for one more shot well
that's another thing isn't it yeah
probably at that point it's it's
literally an addiction I also wonder
because the question you just asked
couldn't be more fascinated can you
generate your own heat as opposed to
like I've been thinking about like how
the Golden Globes or the Emmys they just
have the Emmys or the Oscars like are
these gifts sometimes I go like what a
bunch of [__] but I'm like or is it
like a a nice thing that we all agree to
do going like look Denzel Washington you
made it well we're going to make an
award that even you had to wait until
well training day was a second but you
know what I mean we're gonna wait for a
long time to give you a reason to keep
doing it because human beings are like
meaning making animals yeah and we'll
even make meaning for others because
like
Petey that wants to prove it to somebody
like I love winning somebody over yeah I
love winning a new thing over like going
like I can like a little bit of that
Jordan like I can do this I can do this
but once you've proven enough of those
things
I I do catch myself going like well if I
did this then maybe I could just like
slowly fade away or meaning like find
balance in a different like I think this
is interesting to you right like at what
point do you take even more for you and
your family and and even more energy
away from just your climbing Mountain
stuff but and that's it is are you good
at the thing because you actually enjoy
the puzzle of the thing and like
actually there's it's impossible to turn
that off or is it that you were good at
the puzzle and then someone said you can
be good at the puzzles and there's all
these extrinsic external rewards for it
and then we sort of conflate the two I I
don't think I'm the authority yeah I
don't I really don't but I would like to
think you could be really good at what
you do maybe not like some sort of
objective like the number one person
because maybe that takes a certain level
of extraness yeah but that you could
just be world class at something and do
it because you like being world class at
it that the close I'd love to hear your
answer the closest I come and stand up I
go like that actually when it goes well
yeah not Vegas yeah uh but when it if I
go into The Comedy Store and I perform
and there is a little bit of a
competition not it's not nasty but if
you're if you blow the doors off and it
wasn't a good room that's a great
feeling and it's like you know it's up
I've never done cocaine but I have to
imagine just what cocaine feels like you
have a very Invincible happy feeling and
I'll be a little bit more balanced
through the week okay because I kind of
like met that yeah specialness need
um the other stuff I'm not so sure like
I'm haunted and I'd love to know your
answer here's 300 million dollars yeah
and then it's like what do you keep
doing
I can tell you I would keep doing
stand-up yeah but and I could tell you I
would keep tell me your what's your
answer and what goes through your mind
when you consider yourself I mean it's
it I Think It's Tricky stand up I'm
jealous of stand up because you it's
it's this weird equalizing thing inside
your like what other sort of profession
has like this thing where everyone
submits their pretenses and equalizes
themselves in a sort of humble setting
and just does the thing yeah you know
what I mean like
um there isn't really that'd be like if
I mean we also had these pickup games
yeah or something which I guess they do
but it it's not really that's not how it
works it's how it works yes yeah and
that that is sort of very pure so so the
thing is just doing the thing and
getting the reaction from the audience
the purest form of it like exists and
you can just do it and then you you do
see most of the really big objectively
successful top people and the thing
still do that and with writing though I
see a lot of writers get very successful
and then they don't really write books
anymore or they they find other stuff
that is similar but they don't do the
hard thing of the thing does that keep
going I like the hard thing I do mostly
the hard thing but even even even that
though like there's a hello when I was
finishing this book
um I was like sitting at home one day I
guess it's in the middle of the day and
my six-year-old was like sitting at the
table coloring I guess he was five then
and he said I'm sorry you lost your job
dad and I was like what he's like I'm
sorry you lost your job writing books
and he had just thought like I wasn't
doing it anymore but I was doing it like
a lot I was just doing it like less like
a crazy person right and so it's like so
he didn't recognize it it ceased to
exist as like a thing that was like
stressing him out and it was it was a it
was like one of those weird things like
I didn't it was a weird like offhand
remark that I don't think maybe he even
didn't mean it but that's what it meant
to me yeah and it was just like one of
those like like offhanded observations
that kids could make but I was like oh
yeah that's what I but that's to me that
that is a harder needle to thread and
thing to do than to sell a book that's
sold however many millions of copies
right like more people although not that
many people can be really objectively
successful how many of them can do it
and are not like Monsters or unbalanced
crazy people are right and achieving
that it's really difficult going back to
Jordan yes kind of creating Phantoms to
keep yourself going yes it's a really
special thing to because I'm with you so
when I did a network sitcom
bigley and I were talking about it I was
like it's funny man I have this movie
idea I've had this movie idea for many
years and I was like since I've been
doing this show I was totally happy with
this but I was like I haven't really
been working on the idea the movie idea
yeah because it's hard yeah and where
bigly goes I kind of I don't want to say
I call [__] on this but it's very
easy to be Master Splinter in this
moment and be like that's why I don't do
those things but he was talking about
the risk of comfort and the risk of
getting the sweet gig which that was and
then he's like what won't you make
because your train came in in this way
let's let's be completely clear networks
that comes pay more money than other
jobs that's what we're talking about
yeah you're like why would you bust your
ass for two three years writing a movie
for maybe what you would make in a
couple weeks on a on a sitcom and and
that's a dangerous question yeah and
you're it's one thing uh you have no
control but it's certain the other thing
you don't have a new control and it's
uncertain so why would you choose the
other why do you like the difficult
thing I mean that's super interesting
well I mean I I think writing is the job
writing is the thing and then all like
share girls trade once made this
distinction I saw between writing and
Publishing which I really like oh wow
and like writing is the thing that I
like doing and writing is the thing that
ultimately is sort of up to me and only
I can do this is a stand-up you could
have a stand-up yeah and and so like
that I also think like what kind of
success is it that the reward for it is
not doing the thing that you're good at
and that you previously found a lot of
meaning and happiness in how how is it a
reward to stop doing the thing that used
to give you Joy yes yeah no that's
because you're busy or whatever well let
me put this to you because publishing
and writing love it I was I just was Val
and I just had lunch and I was we talk
about our goals and dreams and like
where we're headed like your your
Herculean where are we going what are we
doing is comfort really the goal
whatever it is and I was like you know
what it is if like if I had whatever the
number is let's say it's 10 million
dollars it's like here you go that's
money more money than you need for your
life for your life for your family's
like here you go
um I'm like I would keep doing stand-up
writing but I wouldn't Chase filming
specials publishing yeah that's true
that's not fun yeah nobody likes going
around being like do you want a special
like it might be fun to be Bill Burr or
or you know but do you think if you were
just purely doing stand-up for that
reason and then you were like this is my
best work then you're like I would do a
special but the spec and I wonder if
that would actually make a better
special because there wouldn't be any
like thirst in it it would just exist as
the you know what I'm saying yeah I
absolutely do I've caught myself I love
writing TV Pilots as well and TV shows
and episodes and all that sort of stuff
and it's a very tricky thing when you
start writing the show to sell like
you're like this will sell yeah as
opposed to you know what my artistic
goal is and you see this with Chappelle
and whatever others it's like and
sometimes I say this to the audience I
go let's stop pretending there's an
after this show let's do stand up as if
we're terminally ill sure let's do stand
up as if at the end of the show the
whole theater explodes
that is the show can you imagine like I
would love to see me yeah do stand up if
I knew at the end of this we're done
sure because no accountability you could
just say what you're thinking this this
is what makes you know I'm not trying to
be funny like old people at the end of
their lives entertaining if they if they
can get there well that is the weird
thing like when you when people think
about death or they go and asteroids
come into Earth what we do and they go
like it'd be chaos because they try
heroin or you know they do like crazy
but it's it's more like no you already
started this thing and now you know it's
the last time you get to do that thing
how how would you do it yeah like
there's an internet meme that's like um
and they say it's from the movie Sandlot
but it's not in the movie sand lot but
it's like there was this time time that
you went out to play with all your
friends and you didn't know it was the
last time you would do it yikes and then
it sort of hits you like right there but
so it's more time you pick up your kids
yeah or or any of those they get too big
yeah right exactly uh it but uh so if
you were if you're people are like like
you're sending this email you're like
it's the last email you're ever will
send or you're gonna die tomorrow they'd
be like well I just wouldn't send the
email so it's like a way of not having
to wrestle with like now what would you
do if you were just fully present in the
thing but I also think the test is good
there's a line in meditations where
Marcus really says you're afraid of
death because you won't be able to do
this anymore and that this is like fill
in the blank like so you're like oh yeah
I want to live forever but like you hate
what you're doing right now and so you
are killing it yeah and so if you think
about it more like no like buddy this is
one of those things that makes me want
to be alive that's a good thing yes yes
I have again lunch with Ali I almost
said this to her but I didn't I'll say
it to you I've been noticing I'll get
really stressed out about something and
one of the thoughts that will sort of
rescue me is I go momentum or yeah I go
you could die now yeah is this how you
want to feel when you die like for sure
meaning like I'm harping on something
right I always liken it to it my brain
is changing TV channels and it's just
looking for stuff to freak me out yeah
it's like is this going to make you
obsessed is this going to make you
anxious it's like the horror movie
theater in my brain and I go
it's like I said with the stand-up don't
kid yourself yeah again it's probably a
Sandlot moment but the Buddha is
purported to say it's attributed to the
Buddha the mistake you make is thinking
you have time yeah and when I remind
myself
let's say I'm on the highway you could
get T-boned right now do you really want
to be grinding your teeth going like
like really yeah I'm all for feeling our
feelings I'm not about denial but how
long are we going to let this go on yeah
yeah yeah you're you're paying with your
most precious resource which is your
time this yeah and then I'm hoping not
to die in so much of my time is just
being like
super stupid but also super funny that
is one thing so I was talking to to Manu
once the the basketball player and and
he was saying that
um and a lot of the athletes I've talked
to after they've retired have said
something similar where they're like I
wish I had more fun while I was doing it
yeah right because the competitiveness
makes it not fun they only get to do it
for a short amount of time and he they
had this sort of devastating loss in uh
in the finals to the he and he was sort
of he was like like it was like a
funeral in my house it was so bad and
then he's like but I just played in the
NBA Finals like this is the dream like I
get to do the thing and I should enjoy
and I do like writing in the past has
often been very miserable for me partly
because I felt I had something to prove
or I felt like I like it was this battle
for control with me and like the
publisher or whatever or I had like
certain Ambitions for it and then now I
feel like I have more confidence and I'm
just like I'm one place this is
manifested with like I would I would
have anxiety about deadlines like I have
to get it in by this time which means
blah blah and then this might sound a
little like divish but I'm like they'll
wait for me like like it the book will
be the book right so like what do I what
do I why am I not enjoying it while I'm
doing it because I'm worried that I
might hit the not hit the deadline and
then by the way that's actually just
taking away time from working on the
book and I'll probably I probably will
hit the deadline it's just not hitting
the deadline it's not an existential
like problem it's that's in my head they
don't care like and in fact if I didn't
hit the deadline maybe like how much
more time do you need and so like why
can't you give yourself that gift now
and then just actually do the thing give
yourself the love you're waiting for
them to give you because it's all just
made up yes they're just giving it to
it's a pretend exchange it's like
Bitcoin it's not it's not real oh they
would say all money is not real that's
true yeah no that's right Bitcoin was
founded on the principle there's a math
interior so it's more real it's more
real that's right I my life was changed
I used to be very anxious about getting
to shows on time because I'd be driving
a rental car to a college and I I just
Mike Brad this comic I worked with very
funny guy
we were traveling together which was
such a gift I got to see how other more
experienced comedians traveled and we
were running late to this show and he
goes there's no show without us and I
was like
yeah oh my God and there's no book
without you it's not arrogant it's just
like relax this is why what came to mind
when you're talking about your guy
wishing he had enjoyed the playoffs or
not been like a funeral when they lost
it's like this is why I think we love
movies about like and I just considered
this if 90 I'm going to make myself 90.
90 year old Pete is in a death bed and
it goes like you can go back and live
that day where you interviewed Ryan for
the third time on your couch I would be
like
there's kid no I'm not I'm not looking
because you're talking about like
there's Katie and like there's Ryan look
at my
like a beginning yeah sure this is why
we love uh A Christmas Carol like all
these things where it's like if
something could just snap us out
I think neurologically we're talking
about grooves I'm like not their podcast
yeah sure and again we're back to that
thing if I was like if we knew we were
gonna blow up yeah after this
conversation would have them but that's
what I'm trying to it all comes down oh
I would just actually show up and be
there for it I wouldn't like yes think
about this or that or want it to be a
certain way I would it would just be
what it is yeah and that that seems to
be the place that all
philosophy and spiritual Traditions are
trying to get you towards right
certainly meditation and over and
speaking meditation you do it by doing
it over and over and over and literally
creating a new habit of being present I
I noticed the other night I came home
I had two podcasts and then I drove home
which as you know is a longer commute
now so I had been in the car for like
three hours that day and then I had like
probably four hours of podcasting then I
went home and I was trying to get home
by six so Val could go to this dance
class all that sounds fine on paper but
so I had to go from work mode and
driving mode which isn't the most chill
mode to instantly putting a
four-year-old to bed sure and I noticed
because at least I'll say this about
when I'm suffering at least when I'm
suffering I go you're suffering yeah I'm
really look at you you can't stop and
what I was doing was
not only do I have to put Lila down I
wasn't just showing up for putting Leela
down which by the way I've made this
point a million times is a pleasure if
you look at it she's testing you she she
wants to see if you're down to clown
where the boundaries are and if I knew I
I was visiting that moment from my 90
year old deathbed I would have been are
you [__] kidding me my four-year-old
daughter I would have
exploded into ecstasy for that
opportunity but I couldn't stop going
this isn't fair yeah I'm building a
story I've been working all day
I need to talk about shifting gears
that's really the issue I need a
threshold time I should have been able
to like take a shower just a shower just
to like go into down whatever but uh
just a sob story and then I'm going and
when she's down I still have to do the
intro and then right there's this
breathing technique we've been doing it
takes 30 minutes I'm like then it's
bedtime and I'm like that's my [__]
day like like immediately what am I
doing you're extrapolating I'm I'm
making a problem yeah through
extrapolation yeah but like that's why I
find it helpful and I'd love to hear
your thoughts on this but like there's a
part of us that wants that or at the
very least I would say is addicted to it
yeah of course well I remember this is
maybe like six months ago or a year ago
I put my oldest down and there was like
a limited amount of daylight so it's
like in the summer like when I put them
down then I can go like work out after
uh otherwise I feel like work out inside
because it's dark and so I was like okay
I'm gonna get to go for a run and so I
get them down and then like uh go
outside and put my shoes and getting
ready and then he's like appears you
know like how they appear after like it
just appears and can I say you know this
if you have plans that hinge on they'll
go down easily yeah they will not go
down either yeah it was probably an
energy thing yeah they feel it you're
trying to like do something or things
aren't set or whatever you're going to
disappear anyways he like pops out and
like I don't know where it came from but
my first thought wasn't like God damn it
like I won't be able to do the run like
shuffling the time I was like oh I get
to do it again and uh I was I was I was
like oh that's how I should think about
all the stuff like I get to do it again
yeah um because it actually is wonderful
and like you said at the end of your
life you'd be like I would kill for one
more time to do that yes and then here
it is and I'm mad because it's
interfering with this made up series of
events that's right that I'm hoping
don't even exist yes that hinge on
things like night time yeah and sleep
and they're just like abstractions sure
we do this all the time it's like we
went to bed at like 9 9 30 so I was
probably asleep by 9 30 last night baby
gets up at 5 30. that was plenty of
sleep yeah 5 30 the numbers five three
zero are making you suffer yeah not how
you feel yeah not if you got enough rest
you did but like your brain again is
used to it or the famous line from The
Stokes is that it's not events that
upset us it's our opinion about events
yeah and so yeah like that's it there's
another quote it's not what happens to
us that torments us it's our thoughts
about yeah probably everything
the idea that like it just is right like
like I when I talk to like hedge funds
and stuff I go like you know like a bull
market in a bear Market do not exist
these are made up things that we've come
to describe a made-up thing which is the
economy like the market doesn't exist
either it's just people doing stuff and
then you've made up a concept and then
you've made up whether it's a good
version of that concept or a bad version
of that concept and then you like pull
your hair out but like it just exists it
just is it just is yeah and I mean
that's obviously you're not going to be
good at trading if you don't want if you
don't understand what these things are
but understanding that they are
abstractions should help you actually be
better at it because then you're like oh
like a hedge fund what's difference
between like a hedge fund and you're
like a value investor a value investor
just needs the market to go up but like
a really great investor can also make
money when the market goes down so it
isn't there is no positive or negative
like it just it just is and you take
advantage of it one way or another and
and that's obviously easier said than
done but like it's it's the project like
I need it to be a certain way or it
should be a certain way or it's unfair
if it's a certain way that's the source
of the suffering or the distress but it
does not exist
I I think it's Chinese Zen it might be
taoism it says the great way is not
difficult for those who have no
preferences and I'm just like oh that's
the whole thing this is pulled right out
of my own thought uh my own brain and
I've said it before but I want to hear
your reaction to it when I there was a
flight out of Montreal is all Comedians
and the flight was like delayed
something like six hours or something it
was like a really it was a thick delay
yeah and it was something like a 6 a.m
flight or something so we'd all none of
us had slept right so I understand some
people got mad yeah uh and I remember
they were mad at Delta and I was like
again like you with your kid I don't
know why that day Buddha Pete showed up
and Buddha Pete was like there is no
Delta there's this plane yeah sure you
could argue that noticing a pattern of
reliability or whatever and employees
and a fleet of plans yeah we agree to
call it Delta but like you're bull bear
it's not it's not real it's just this
pla it's like when you get and if you
get mad at the game yell at this person
that is
that's like Equus thinking a horse's you
know God it's like you're just picking
one point of the thing and being like
you will be Delta yeah yeah I I try to
think too like
so that means also like okay I'm not
going to tell myself this is a bad thing
but then that also means that you have
the power to tell yourself it's a good
thing so you could be like this is a
[__] Adventure I'm like what are 200
comedians on the same delayed flight
what's that gonna look like we had a
great time and we've both been alive
long enough to know you don't even
remember the flights that are on time
yeah the story is the six hour delay and
we did have a we I had fun with a lot of
those people yeah and I've taken that
flight so many times with no problem and
those are gone they're shredded as
they're happening maybe we said this
last time but I'd like to call it
Nostalgia for the president if you can
if you can somehow
the quality of nostalgia we love talking
about book titles I have that written
down as a possible that is interesting
that sounds like one of those Buddhist
things that means nothing and everything
at the same time
High Praise yes but we're like putting
your children down yeah if you could be
nostralgic for that yes
um you know who Scott Galloway is uh
he's like a marketing business sort of
Guru guy he he said this thing to me
once that I think about a lot now which
is the sort of same thing but the
opposite of it he was saying that like
he was looking at a picture of his like
eight-year-old and he was grieving his
eight-year-old because that
eight-year-old's now a 12 year old yeah
like that person is gone that's right
he's like it's still great that he's an
awesome 12 year old but he's not the
eight-year-old anymore yeah and the idea
that like you'll grieve this moment
um is really interesting because then I
think it makes you present it also it's
helped me like you know when you have
kids that are like they'll be walking
soon and then you're like I can't wait
for him you you're not only not enjoying
the present you're like fast forwarding
and wishing for this other thing that
you're gonna miss now and that's that's
a very weird thing that we do and so if
you're just like it's sort of is what it
is and like I'm gonna actually enjoy
while it's here I to me is
that that requires weirdly a kind of an
active process but like is really
where it's at I completely agree where
so you've calmed down your son thinking
you lost your job came from a lot of
effort for you what were those efforts
and what so I'm doing like a four books
I think where I came from is I'm doing a
four book series so I I've this is the
second one and then I'm in but the way
it works is like I'm now Midway through
the third and then I have to start
thinking about the fourth so like wow
one is coming out I'm starting the other
um but just going like I think having
some kind of job security is unique in
like my profession because books are
normally like a one-off thing so you
write a proposal you have an idea for a
book you sell then you go make that
thing and then you have to go do that
but like the idea is like this is what
I'm doing for the next four or five
years yeah like I can have some comfort
in it you're on the wire now yeah and
and I I've liked that where it's like I
know what I'm supposed to be doing and
then also
I told myself at the beginning whether
this is true or not but I was like
series take time to develop their
audience so like how the first one does
or even the second one does is not
representative of how the whole thing
will do in fact you need to finish all
four to give the whole thing a chance so
then like how the first one did I didn't
really care because I'm writing the
second one how the second one does I
don't like obviously I want to do well
but I don't care that much because I'm
working on the third one so like I've
I've just like I've just I think I'm
just more chill about it because like
I'm realizing that all I don't feel any
pressure to do that stuff even though
the the pressure hasn't actually the
pressure didn't exist before but now I
found a reason or a story to talk myself
out of the pressure and so I can just
sort of be and I I would like to think
it's contributing to a better product
but even if the product was it I can
safely say it's not making like a
hundred percent worse product right yeah
it's not garbage but even if it was 20
worse I would take that trade any day
interesting these are your three points
yes you're shooting three pointers now
yeah yeah I would take away I would
trade I would trade worse yeah because
it's ultimately more sustainable yeah
right like I'm not gonna burn myself out
not gonna drive people away I'm not
going to torture myself you know yeah
and the whole point is that I want to be
able to do it for a long time like
they're especially investing yourself
yeah exactly yeah exactly there's not
there isn't some like biological
deadline that is looming the way that
there would be for certain professions
and sports yeah but uh it's interesting
we're back to what we were just talking
about which is like if you sell three
books yeah there's a real risk of going
like well [__] the seduction is over
I'll admit that I love
the sale it's hard for me to not there's
a rush to it for sure yeah you want that
and then you burn off that for a while
and then and then you know there's the
thick of it and then there's the
follow-through and all of that stuff but
is there is there more
uh need to motivate yourself it sounds
like there's less it sounds like you're
good with this coasting or this cruising
altitude I don't know I don't know I
yeah I don't know I think if if the work
is requiring you to be present and
connected and like reach some sort of
deep Insight I don't know if being like
hungry and aggressive and like zero-sum
is actually the attitude that you want
to bring towards it that's the
interesting thing right like
um let's say like ego for instance ego
probably helps in like the entertainment
and adjacent businesses because like you
have this need to get out there and be
seen and like you know ask for stuff
that you have no you haven't oh well
sorry I was trying to get that glare off
your face you have you have no uh right
to ask for you know you're more
Shameless whatever all this stuff but
then it hurts because the whole point is
creating an empathetic connection like
speaking to some part of the going
inwards and finding something so like I
I just don't know if that sort of like
uh
desperation or thirst is
the fuel that people want it's like it's
fuel but it's destroying the engine
you've done a lot of work though to
realize that a a calm steady quiet
workspace of self-motivation it took a
lot of it sounds like effort and study
to realize step outside of it and go
like that thirst that like drive that
most of us are looking for like the Red
Bull feeling yeah is not right you're
trying to enjoy it for its own sake
you're trying to do the work yeah I
actually think that the other one's
easier like it's easier to be like if I
don't do this like I'm dead yeah yeah
I'm dead yeah yeah right or if I need to
do this to prove X Y like it or like I
need to be the best in the world like
there's a um uh it's based on the
exchange between uh Alexander the Great
and diogenes the cynic but
um which is this interesting
unique moment in history where the most
powerful ambitious person in the world
the most insatiable conqueror repeatedly
bumps up against
who's not just a philosopher but he's
sort of
like in the Buddhist sense like sort of
pushed everything away like he sold all
his possessions he wanders the streets
um and there's a fictional exchange that
I think about
um in it's in one of Stephen
pressfield's books uh so it's not real
but so some version of it uh I'll tell
you the real one after but he says
um like Alexander the Great looks at him
he says I have conquered the world what
have you done and he's like I have
conquered the need to conquer the world
wow and the real exchange is Alexander
the Great finds diogenes and he's like
sort of laying there sunbathing and he
goes I'm the most powerful man in the
world what can I do for you and uh
Chinese looks at him and he says you can
stop blocking the Sun and so he's like
he just has no need for him whatsoever
yeah he's like in and I'm I'm not saying
I'm there at all but I'm I'm saying it's
like it's easier actually to want to
conquer the world I agree than to want
to conquer the world and work yourself
obviously there's a whole percentage of
the populations like why would I want to
do that that's never even thought about
it I think that the harder thing is like
if you're an ambitious driven person
who's good who can make a lot doing
these different things
to work through that and not be driven
by it that's harder yeah that's really
interesting this this
um teacher guy named sad Guru talks
about desire
and it's like even if you let's say you
Ryan really think about it too if you
ruled the entire world everything goes
through you yeah ultimate power sure
however that looks just you could never
pay a bill again you can get all your
friends off you can just wield it
however you want he's like how long
would you rule the world before you'd
start looking at the moon and then if
you own the moon how long before you
start looking at Mars you see it like
I'm not even putting it down I'm just
saying it's the nature of The Human
Condition Elon Musk I should own Twitter
yes exactly because I although is that
him doing what we were saying at the
beginning picking something that you
know is gonna kind of sure
yeah yeah some creative cast but it's
like of course he's looking at Mars
because if you if you're eating every
cake yeah you go like I wonder what cake
would taste like on a planet that's red
or has a different atmosphere or
whatever it is like it's just an
interesting thing isn't the real power
um it's not it would I'm trying to be
too poetic by saying powerlessness but
real power is to
have it but not need it and and and be
small enough to just sunbathe on the
beach well it is interesting because I
forget who said it there's some uh some
great guy who's saying like you know
like it's very comforting to mediocre
people to tell themselves that like
great people are unhappy right like as a
way to not have to do so but that's what
I think is so fascinating about stoicism
because like when you think about most
of the philosophical schools the people
sort of preemptively stepped away from
like a certain race or a certain thing
right they're like I'm gonna fall go
inward I'm gonna seek this sort of
spiritual enlightenment what's so
interesting like Marcus realist isn't
just like oh he's a he's a philosopher
and he's like adjacent to power he is he
assumes the purple as they would say in
Rome like he he becomes Caesar like
literally he's a regular person and then
he gets the name Caesar and is the most
powerful person in the world he's
worshiped as a god God and he he talks
in meditations he's just like I want to
avoid being imperialized like avoid
being dyed purple like he actually is
that and like meditations is a document
where the most powerful person in the
world is is like sensing themselves
looking at the moon and going like you
don't need to worry about the moon you
know like uh like he has this he has
he's not like me going Alexander the
Great why was he you know he's he's he
could do anything that Alexander the
Great did he has all that power he could
be like I'm going to conquer this
country I'm gonna do this like uh I
could I'm going to change Junior's
Caesar renames one of the the months of
the year he's like that's me now you
know July that's me now uh and and uh
like he could do that I didn't know that
yeah so August is from Augustus uh
Julius Caesar is July but and um Marcus
aurelius's stepfather the emperor before
him his name is antoninus Pius he's
offered I'm sure you've never heard of
um he is offered the chance to name a
month after him he said I don't need it
and so like I think it's also the
example that he's following but like
it's interesting to think that he has
it's like one of the only times in
history where
because typically the people that end up
in power are people to whom from day one
power has been the whole thing yeah and
so here you have this person who's
ambitious and talented and great but
sort of thrust way above what he would
ordinarily have been at and then all the
philosophical things are now being
tested in a real way and it's like does
he mean them and I I just I'm writing
about Harry Truman a lot in the book I'm
writing now and uh
uh when Harry when Theodore Roosevelt
said uh Teddy uh Franklin Roosevelt
suddenly dies
um this basically like small town farmer
who doesn't go to college uh is
president of the United States and uh
someone one of like the newspaper
writers at the time goes what an
incredible experiment in democracy this
is that just like a regular dude is now
the dude that does that's not his movie
King Ralph yeah that hasn't happened
very many times and it would require a
pretty incredible person not to be
corrupted by that thing and it's so
shocking to me it's so foreign that
someone would go we can name a month
after you which is still endures today
and they're like I'm good like imagine
if someone offered a president will put
you on the five you're gonna take
Lincoln off and it'll be you yeah and
they're like no that's okay yeah that
but that would make more sense you'd be
like too much reverence for Lincoln
we're going to do a three dollar bill
yeah it's going to be you well when when
Trump was president when he visited
Mount Rushmore of course
the governor of is it in South Dakota or
North Dakota I don't know uh whatever
the governor gave him a bust of Mount
Rushmore with his face added to it no
and there was no part of him that was
like this is he like has it it's like
one of his that that that's what he
wants right and no part of him no part
of him I believe that South Dakota I I
awkward about it or like obviously this
is too much you know
um I'm gonna say no well deserved this
is grotesque
I'm not saying it's gross I'm just
saying it it's beyond the pale he's like
finally somebody gets it that is exactly
what I was thinking yeah of course it
was wow so interesting I mean we're at
this is a great conversation about why
we do anything that we do but the fact
that you have these Heroes that one and
so do I I want to put this to you this
is changing gears a little bit so as you
know you live in do you talk about where
you live yeah I live right outside
Austin you live outside of Austin and
when we Val and I were moving to Ojai I
was texting you I was asking you about
and all these different things it's
ended up being the absolute best thing
in the world for for everybody yeah not
just our daughter yeah but for me as
well turns out I'm a real empath I
absorb energy and all that sort of stuff
I'm a sensitive person so we're all
thriving up there and Buddy I'd really
love to hear your thoughts on this I
can't wait for your thoughts on those
for someone who spends a lot of time
deep in spiritual philosophy that the
only true happiness is
um not event based you have to find the
part of you that is made of Happiness uh
we could call this your soul we call
this awareness the still quiet place
inside like so if you turn all your
thoughts down this is meditation you'll
notice that that's sort of vibrating
that the the spring of Life inside of
you is just [__] fine like it's fine
it's better than fine it's Blissful yeah
so that is one of my core beliefs yes
then I moved to Ojai and I go I'm 70
happier I'm like what I honestly like I
wouldn't call it a crisis but Rob Bell
who I love I was like Bobby I don't know
what to do one of my spiritual precepts
is that we need a non-circumstantial joy
and here I am I just did something as
simple as moving my body yeah from one
place to another place and it's it's not
just not dipping it's increasing with
appreciation I was like I don't know how
to reconcile those two things and he
goes it's a paradox he's like both are
true he's like you need that and
sometimes moving is what you need it
like yeah I think they're being way too
hard on yourself though because think
about it this way it's like you
shouldn't lose your temper at people
especially people that you care about
it's easier not to do that when you're
not hungry
like right so like obviously they're
sort of objectively like what's good and
bad or right and wrong and the standards
you try to hold yourself to but like
it's easier to be good at basketball
when you've slept eight hours it's
harder to do it when you're hungover or
you're not in shape or whatever right
like it's it the the idea that
environmental factors shouldn't
contribute to the thing like you should
be able to to be a great creative you
have to be able to do what you do
anywhere but you should also have like
an office and a space that is part of a
routine that brings it out better and it
more consistently that you're not having
to White Knuckle it yeah I loved you
said it in a sentence it's like it's
easier to not lose your temper and by
the way we got to talk about this my dad
text you this is so how funny is it Ryan
my idea we talk about stuff like this
all the time my dad texted me today to
uh get in touch with the son of some
friend of his who's in L.A by the way
the last time I did that it ended up
being a lovely conversation what I don't
like about it is there's no ask yeah
there's no and there's no no there's no
there's no no on the table Yeah because
unfortunately my wounded child self has
learned that the quickest way to end
this
and I'm going to call it an altercation
I don't think it is to my dad yeah for
me it feels like this I completely blow
it out of proportion because of whatever
is going on inside of me and I overreact
and I'm like the quickest way to end
this is to just do it yeah but I say to
Val I'm like
it's like a pts thing a PTSD thing I go
right into like a fear place we were
having lunch at a restaurant nearby and
I was just like all these people can go
meaning [__] all these people everybody
here like I went from Pete yeah what I
like to think of as Pete to like [__]
everybody [__] everything I Hate
Everything I don't even want to do this
podcast like I had to work through it
and I was like how funny is it dude that
it was the day you were doing the
podcast he doesn't do that very often
and by the way I love my dad I
understand but like the dynamic is like
to me
you you do this because you're my son
like you have to do this for me because
I'm asking for sure and I'm just like I
would [__] in my hat if it just included
I'm sorry to be a bother yeah especially
when it's probably like the thing that
by the way when I wasn't good or highly
paid at it you saw no value in
whatsoever yeah
there's for sure there's a sort of like
now that it's good for you socially with
your friends it's something you care
about but when I was not good at it
there was all sorts of judgment yeah
that for sure and also like now it's a
commodity that you can trade yeah that
you go he's busy but I can make him show
up and the times that I have yeah
um not
forget it it's like the worst thing in
the world that I could do like like
really almost like
it's it it's Chinese
because there's no there's that muscle
in our in our family was just never
exercised at all so if I go like you
know what Dad no it would just be like
oh okay like almost like silent
treatment like really he knows that if
he does nothing my own guilt will flare
up so hot that I'll that I'll give in
and yeah I hate what I'm telling you
right now that's why I just do it yeah
because I'm like I feel powerless and
upset and I'm like how are you with all
this stuff is there are there updates
family stuff yeah I mean I've I've
definitely found like my marriage is
better the less I am in contact with my
parents
and actually I would say I didn't find
this I was informed that this is the
case by your wife yes because she's Tom
she's doing the good Tom Brady yeah
she's going you need to draw this
boundaries yeah so the energy is just
different and yeah I'm sure it's a
million reasons why but that that is a
that is a real to go to your point about
like I should be happier where I should
be happy wherever I live but you can
live wherever you want so you live there
and it's better but the hard part is
like okay uh if your life is better
without certain people in it
um is your obligation to having a better
life or is your obligation to your
parents or to this like how you hate
your boss should you but should you keep
going to that job or should you get a
different job that yeah how much are you
clinging to the identity that you're not
the kind of person that like slowly
backs away from your family yeah yeah
yeah and those are the Commodities on
the table sorry to keep saying
Commodities but it's like one of them is
like your feeling of being a good son
yeah like so there probably is a part of
me that's like look I'll do it and if
I'm in my best possible mood maybe I'd
even do that but or there's like
Val and I one of the reasons we moved to
Ohio was our little Mantra was good life
when like have you noticed that like
people are just like
oh I'll just uh we'll do that later
we'll do that later people do that later
we'll do that later I said you're dead
and then you're dead Ryan I've seen that
you're twice twice in my life because so
first off we moved out to Texas we live
in the country we have like a farm we
have some animals and stuff and people
go I've always wanted to do that yes as
if as if there's some like uh force
field yeah or like test you have to pass
or whatever right like it's I guarantee
you it certainly was then the farm cost
less than your apartment in New York
City you know what I mean like you could
do it you just don't want to do it Val
and I talk about this all the time not
to be the special people that got out
but we noticed that there's a cert we
call it the the spell yeah like there's
a spell has been cast that keeps a
certain choice and Ojai is also pricier
being outside of Austin this price here
but these things don't have to be in
these Chic areas yeah but we get that
too is like you got out you did it I've
always thought about doing that or we
get the extreme uh I'll write mockery uh
why would you do that people will say I
don't understand how you could drive an
hour and a half into the City and then
in the next sentence tell me that they
drove an hour to their kids school and
an hour back and I'm like the drive to
my daughter's school I'm going to tell
you how to go ready uh left right right
it's on the left yeah and I was like
it's it's a 10 minute drive sure and I I
just I'm excited to talk to you about
this well since I saw you last I opened
a bookstore in like I know I saw you the
same thing people like oh I've always
wanted to do and again it it was harder
to do than opening than starting than
moving to the country but again it's
like it's a thing literally anyone could
could do there's not there again there's
no like certification yes
um nobody's gonna ask for a badge the
the cost of doing it is not any more
than the office space you're paying for
for you and your seven that's exactly
what I'm saying the the hour to and from
your kids school is the same hour and a
half that it would be to and from a
small town yeah but like
what is it is it cultural indoctrination
or I I couldn't tell you I think it's
fear I mean it's like they want to do it
but they don't want the cost of it
potentially not working yeah the
embarrassment Yeah well yeah the you
don't want to do something different
because then you have to explain why you
did it and then it's weird that you did
it yeah
um and then yeah what if it doesn't work
like if although this is how a friend of
mine lives in Austin and then they
decided to move home to be closer to his
parents in somewhere in the Midwest and
they hate it and they move back and uh I
actually like really respected it that
like that they admitted that they didn't
like it and just did it you know what I
mean like they didn't just be like I
guess we live here in this place that we
hate forever I have a joke you're gonna
love it I think it's about how my dad
was on Uber and he was trying to tip the
Uber driver and I I said dad just give
me the phone I'll do it for you because
I could he was just pushing buttons
willy-nilly I took the phone he was he
had swapped to ubereats and there were
it was three dozen 36.
steamed vegetable dumplings in his
ubereats cart and one more Mash they
would have been delivered to the Italian
restaurant
that's all fun it's a good story but the
part that I that really hits me in the
heart every time I do it is I go and my
dad is a proud man that means he would
have eaten
36. sure he would have been like dipping
them in marinara that's a good combo
good mashup because rather than sure and
it can actually make me a little
emotional because I know I can be this
way too rather than saying like you know
Peter I'm confused a lot of the time
technology is overwhelming to me and I I
really made a mistake I don't I don't
eat vegetable tumbling like that it's
just not on the menu so your guy or a
girl that moved to the Midwest and came
back
that I'm gonna say it that's delicious
that's something you don't see enough of
is just I say this all the time but I
want to say it to you
um there's a gaming design company that
has a slogan they put on the wall that
says fail faster yeah and it's just like
just failure is good yeah you get so
much data from failing just do it faster
go and move in fact people should have
failed faster outside of Austin before
it became the hot spot of entertainment
in the country well the weird part was
when I was thinking about doing it
um a bunch of people were telling me
that I shouldn't do it but that wasn't
super persuasive to me but I I was like
I'm going to call Tim Ferriss Tim if I
shouldn't do it Tim will have a very
good reason why I shouldn't do it yeah
and he was like oh I think he should do
it and I was like oh this is very
surprising to me and why and he was like
how he said how are you going to know
whether you like running a bookstore
unless you've run a bookstore and I was
like oh that's he's like so just you're
like the movie he's like don't say I'm
doing it forever yeah just say I'm gonna
try this thing yes and if you see it as
an experiment then there is an outcome
either way and you're not like your
identity isn't tied to it has to work or
it doesn't have to work and that was
actually his advice when I was thinking
about starting a podcast he's like just
do like 10 say I'm gonna do 10 and then
if you like doing it after 10 continue
doing it but if you don't you have an
out you just said a mouthful or use Tim
did and you're saying the same thing
which is like when you tie your identity
to the thing it in your mind I think it
becomes life or death yeah it's like if
you say I am a success and then you fail
then you're humiliated yeah if you say
I'm an adventurer I'm a [__] Hobbit
yeah I open bookstores I mean I have to
think it's not a prudent you know I
don't think a business investor would be
like bookstore yeah yeah no it's really
not against your name written yeah yeah
I mean what did you just say it's
certainly not a get rich quick scheme
like it's like a terrible idea but you
love bookstores like yeah and and I did
it in a way that it wasn't it was easier
than maybe people would think it would
be and it's actually been amazing and
like yeah my kid goes to school down the
street and like uh the painted porch
the painted porch yeah yeah I saw you
put up some wonderful uh solidarity
stuff during the reproductive marches
and all that stuff I thought that was
really cool and no and it's actually
really cool because it's like it's
because I'm not doing it
because I wanted to make a lot of money
and just do whatever I want and I don't
have to like I have a lot of empathy for
all the other businesses on the street
who are like
um yeah if we ask people to wear a mask
during a pandemic they won't come in
yeah and I'm like I don't want people to
come in so like uh people coming in as a
mild inconvenience and so uh like I get
to make I get to make that but if you
think that's actually been helpful for
me too it's like very rarely am I doing
the thing for financial reasons right so
then it should make it easier to do the
right thing when it costs you money
because you already decided that you
weren't doing it for financial reasons
but if you don't have that Clarity then
you default to the financial reasons
we're back to what we're saying it's
it's what if the theater blows up at the
end of the show yeah it's like just do
it yeah just do it for its own sake
you're not keeping anything in reserve
or not trying to upset like this person
or that person if you're like well I
[__] hate this person and I think
they suck I don't want to tell them
though because like yeah uh that would
hurt my chances for some other thing
you're talking about Liberation it's
funny you're talking about it in a
business way but spaciousness
interspaciousness is huge I was just
doing a podcast this morning I was on my
friend Andrew Michonne's podcast a
podcast but outside have you heard of it
edit that out it was outside it was
outside was it walking or was it you sit
at a table and you talk to the people
that come by it was fun like strangers
yeah strangers yeah that's cool yeah
yeah I don't want to blank on what I was
saying
what were we recording this podcast this
podcast no no back podcast are we doing
this one though I think so yes
doing it for its own oh
you realize very I forget why I brought
that up but like when you're not
spacious you you have all these bumpers
it's like operation it's like when I
started doing a certain if you do a
commercial campaign well there's a brand
you can't slander you know what I mean
I'm not saying oh that's why I brought
up Andrew Michelle at the end of it
somebody made a very offensive little
joke just to me I had never met them
before sometimes this happens as a
comedian they just want to say the weird
thing because they know you're a
comedian you'll be fine I was like
that's cool that's that's a type of I
don't care if you come to my store or
not yeah like you can't I'm not saying
you can't offend me I'm sure there's
something you could say that would
offend me but like for the most part you
can just say something untoward and I
just I'm just gonna laugh and that's I
like that quality of being a comedian so
you're bringing that forget about
business
it's a spacious thing to be able to be
like I don't care yeah you don't want to
be beholden how many Masters do you have
yeah can we Whittle that number down
because people customers think it's like
oh the customer's always right but like
yeah that's only true if you have
leverage over the business owner right
yeah and if the if you don't yes but I
think people think like they're like I'm
gonna bite my tongue I'm not gonna do
you know I don't want to rock the boat I
don't get whatever but then when I'm
more successful then of course like I'll
be able to be more free I'll have that
spaciousness but actually the opposite
is true because when early on you could
have done whatever you wanted because it
wouldn't cost anything and now you're
like okay but if I piss this person off
it there's a a monetizable amount I was
actually just um I don't know her name
is this is the catastrophe yeah success
you think it would be freeing but it's
actually constraining I was reading some
piece
um you know like the ATT girl she's like
in all the ATT commercials I don't know
her name but I'm sure she made a makes
an absolute Fortune there's so many
commercials but I was reading some piece
she's just like talking about an
abortion that she had and I was like
they could not want her to be talking
about so whatever you think about Pro uh
about about abortion like I was just
struck by the courage of like the
ordinariness of like
she and she's not like an actress or an
actor in the sense that like your fault
like or she's making her money based on
like her fans like yeah her if like the
five people that make that decision at
ATT decide that's right like we don't
want that heat like that that that gravy
train is over that's right and at the
same time they're like there I read the
story once about Lyndon Johnson
he's becomes president he's trying to
Lyndon B Johnson yes yes sorry Linda
Davis Johnson Lyndon Johnson um
uh he he uh
I I have actually I have a barber shop
it's not it's a Carter story not when
he's not story but anyways he um he goes
uh he starts doing the civil rights
legislation they go I think this would
be better to wait till the second term
or something and he goes oh what the
hell's the presidency for the point is
like what do you have it for that's
right if you're not going to use it for
that thing Val and I just did a podcast
and for some reason I was just a little
more timid and I caught myself not
wanting I I some joke about Joe Rogan
and Joe Rogan is huge yeah it wasn't
even mean it was just kind of like
pointing out that he shoots his own food
or something and then there was
something else that came up and
something came over me where I was like
what the [__] am I doing yeah make fun
of Joe Rogan like just do it like what
is the point of being a clown if you're
not gonna clown around yeah and the
reality is he probably doesn't care at
all he wouldn't care I just told you the
whole thing about being and it wasn't me
be right back and then I'm going to ask
Ryan about ghosts psychics and
unexplainable weird things that I don't
think we've ever talked about before so
we'll be right back to talk about really
weird stuff
pardon the interruption weirdos this
episode is brought To Us by our friends
at next Evo Naturals as you guys know I
love CBD but not all CBD brands are
created equal and if you've ever taken
it and wonder is this even absorbing or
is this ever going to kick in is it
going to be fast acting I mean that's a
problem if you've ever wondered whether
or not your CBD was working that means
it probably wasn't but next Evo Naturals
developed smart sorb technology sounds
like something I would say is a joke is
that smart sword it's smart sword smart
sword technology clinically proven to
help your body absorb CBD four times
better than regular CBD oil because oil
doesn't just mix with your water-based
body it works faster too and when you
feel stress coming on you won't waste
time wondering is this doing anything is
this working I just had my parents visit
and my next Evo samples came in I was so
excited to try all of their different
products but their stress gummies that
have adaptogens and this smartsorb CBD
in it was an absolute Lifesaver now I
don't just take it when I'm stressed out
during that visit I actually take it
every day as a part of my daily
maintenance to keep things even and keep
things just a little bit rounder on the
edges that's what I like to think that
this that next Evo does is it just
Smooths out the edges of your stress and
and helps you ease into your day it is a
wonderful wonderful thing smart sort
technology obviously is changing my
relationship with CD CBD it improves
cbd's ability to be absorbed that's a
key thing getting into your system in as
little as 10 minutes most CBD oil found
in tinctures gummies and capsules
achieve between two percent and ten
percent absorption which means more than
90 of what you think you're getting is
actually being wasted that's why next
Evo Naturals is here to save the day
they're scientifically formulated to
deliver more CBD and a way your body can
actually use and fast proven 29
29 times better absorption in the first
30 minutes so help fight stress with
next Evo Naturals stress CBD complex
with ashwagandha clinically proven to
reduce stress by 70 I can attest to that
this was what saved my butt this whole
uh past month to be honest ashwagandh
and CBD are a powerful combo working
together to Target the source of rising
stress hormones like cortisol next Evo
is the only brand that combines a
patented natural whole plant ashwagandha
that's eight times more powerful than
regular ashwagandha and they're 100 U.S
hemp derived smart smart sword CBD is
four times better absorption than
standard CBD so this is the next level
guys this is the one to try if you've
been dragging your feet on the CBD train
next Evo natural is the one to do get to
the root of stress and with the stress
CBD complex from next Evo Naturals for
up to 20 five percent off subscription
or orders of forty dollars or more use
promo code weird at next evo.com that's
n e x t e v o.com promo code weird and
show your support of this show we're
also brought To Us by our friends at
Adam and Eve listen up guys girls
everybody who wants better sex
that's everybody the best way to get
started is to go to adamandeve.com right
now Adam and Eve is offering 50 off just
about any item and more than that Adam
and Eve wants to make your life easy
they're offering discreet shipping as
your privacy is a priority plus free
shipping on your entire order that's
free and discrete shipping doesn't
matter how much you spend or what you
buy all will be packaged and sent
discreetly for free so bring more
pleasure and satisfaction into your
bedroom just go to adamandeve.com and
select any one item it could be an
adventurous toy or just about anything
you desire just enter code weird at
checkout and you'll receive 50 off
almost any item and when you do you'll
also get free shipping off your entire
order and when you offer sorry when you
enter offer code weird that's
w-e-i-r-d at adamandeve.com weird this
is an exclusive offer specific to this
podcast so be sure to use this code
weird to get not just the discount but
also the 100 free shipping with code
weird thank you to Adam and Eve for your
support of the show all right everybody
let's get back to Ryan holiday
so do you have to do the ads in front of
me right now no way we're already so
weird we're already back in fact that's
the first thing you said after that no
on Corolla you're going stamps.com
this is the teleprompter in front of you
it's a whole thing there's part of me
that envies it because he has a team you
know that is like a streamline I'm not
looking for you Katie to be like why
don't we do that I'm just saying that's
radio
someone he doesn't even know what the ad
is for and he's just like nah apparently
I love stamps.com him and he just does
it in front of the guests
and I just sit there like a schmuck do
you ever do a podcast and they do your
intro in front of you that's the worst I
I don't like the worst nobody wants I've
never done that in person when they do
that but it's like I don't need to hear
this yeah but when you do speaking
events and stuff it'd be like this guy's
a genius don't don't do it don't say
that it's not no one it's not important
at all just let me just let me go up
there and do the thing I completely but
it can hurt if they're just like this
guy is one of the most gifted speakers
or if they say about like there's a
comedy Legend and then they're like no
one knows who I am when I come out it's
like I think we would see him I had a
super bad version of that recently like
uh because of the intro thing the the
they play a video before I talk usually
like videos like some news Clips or
whatever and um I gave a talk they don't
always play the video
um and they were like and today our
speakers Ryan Holland and get up there
and then they played the video as I
stood there and I had to uh
no yeah yeah yeah
just playing over here huge just like
Ryan holiday what are the big fastest
growing I don't know bookstore I want
you to wear a mask
so bad yeah it's the opposite there's a
reason show business it's a show yeah
let's do it like a show well the court
like yeah you're like oh I had to do the
corporate gig and that's like different
all my gigs are corporate gigs right
like which is nice because the audience
isn't my problem like I don't have to
bring the audience if I if I show up at
a thing and there's no seats it's like
obviously I'm empathetic to the host but
that's a them problem like I was paid to
talk at your thing you had to bring the
people there right or all the all the
employees had to come it's your thing I
that's so but the flip side of that is
that uh they're not actually there for
you at all but well with comedy they're
not there for you either like usually
you're in the like the one I did by the
way it wasn't like a catastrophe it just
wasn't what I'm used to yeah like laughs
all the time it was like sporadic oh
that's what you're used to just always
laughing no not always but at least when
you go like and let me tell you that was
a big old booty and no one laughed and
you're like
it's like a terrible feeling it's a
terrible feeling when everyone knows
what you're going for and it's not
happening yeah and you could tell them
that it's like it's noon and we're in
the middle of a corporate award show
yeah nobody understands yeah sorry
there's one last thing on that comedy
clubs work on the idea that the audience
is primed yeah to be a comedy audience
yeah but if it's just a thing that's
happening already yeah and then you come
in as like the the other type of blood
cell and you're just like hey
I've said this before but the feeling
from the crowd was why are you telling
us this sure I'm like my wife and I like
they're just like we don't understand
why you think we care at a comedy club
you can say anything because they're
like we bought a ticket to hear about
the comedians the the weirder one for me
will be like the CEO is a huge fan yeah
and then they because of the CEO they
got to pick who comes to the company
Retreat yeah and so it's like you're
really there for one person that's right
and then everyone else is like why are
we here an audience one yeah yeah and
then uh they're eating it up and then
these other people are just like what is
that and but they it's their business
their name is on the on you only have to
please that one person yeah which I've
done the opposite I've done shows like
that and I like roast the CEO a little
bit and everyone loves it and I'm like I
don't know if I played that the smartest
I could have played because it's not Joe
in sales that goes you know we should
have it was the CEO but actually that
company ended up having me back so it
was all good what about this have you
ever almost died
ever almost died uh I don't think so
come on
you were a kid in the riptide took you
that time you were sleepy at the wheel I
mean I'm sure there's some things like
that but they haven't stuck with me
where I'm like that was a near-death
experience oh really yeah I tend to just
just keep moving just keep moving okay
oh yeah when I remember when I was a kid
I was walking nobody's ever turned
around on me actually I was walking on
the beach with my dad and it was one of
those times where they just like out of
nowhere a huge wave a rogue wave came
and hit us and he said he gripped onto
me for dear life uh so you know you take
take the good with the 30 dump 36
dumplings and he held he's been calling
in that paper for a long time
[Music]
see the weird thing is that he saw that
as like now you owe me you know but he
held on to me and when he said when the
wave cleared I just was Marvel's The
Sandman like I was head to toe you
couldn't even see me and I remember
going to the shower and like washing it
off and everybody was staring at me that
that was what I don't really remember
very much about getting hit by the wave
but I remember everybody in the men's
room being like what happened to that
because it looked like someone had like
cemented me basically so yeah wow I
almost croaked there there are other
times when I was little I remember
confidence being like a tricky cocktail
for a child yeah I feel like I was an
invincible boy there were times when I
would be watching the traffic pattern
and I was like if you just run real fast
now you could make it you know like yeah
and that is true yeah but uh hold your
kid's hand is all of them because my dad
again in that situation what's holding
my hand I was like what are you doing
and I was like oh you were starting to
go for it yeah because I wanted to
impress him I was like he's waiting for
like it to be really clear yeah like
boring clear and I'm like I know how to
do this just go now
so there's two that that come to mind
plus I you know I went to the Amazon and
stuff and like eating weird things and
like I was probably inches from
tarantulas constantly and just like
struggling poisonous spiders yeah no it
was we would walk into the river they
told us not to and we would walk into
the river because we didn't want to wait
for a canoe to canoe us out to where we
would bathe and would just walk through
and I think the reason why they were
like I think that was the bathroom I
think we were walking through like the
village toilet you're gonna die of like
cholera or something absolutely and they
were they were warning us like don't pee
in the river because there are bugs
that'll swim up the stream of your pee
how old were you when you were just
ignoring this pretty basic safety advice
yeah
and we would go in and me and Carl he
was a little Butterball pale kid and uh
he looked like Dennis the Menace would
walk in and would just go sealing it
meaning pressing our butt cheeks
together as if that would prevent oh
ceilings
tight butt tight butt tight butt so yeah
that's about 28 28 times that come to
mind that I almost done
let me ask you this uh kind of going
back to the Ohio outside of Austin thing
are you still enjoying it because I
remember when I told you do you remember
this I was like we're going oh hi and
you were like your daughter will love it
and I remember being like is he [__]
with me
like yeah man like show you thought like
your daughter don't like it and you'll
hate it yeah I thought maybe you were
hinting it like look take it from a guy
who's been under an apple tree for too
long as you were saying no no Arc like
we we ended up having to get a house in
town in the little town that the
bookstore is also because our kids are
like wild animals yeah like because
three or like because of already growing
up at the farm and then growing on the
farm during the pandemic they were just
like yeah they're like we we went over
to someone's house like a couple we now
have to have discussions especially when
we took them on a plane where it's like
this is a place where you pee in the
bathroom like uh this is a place you
have to wear clothes this isn't a pale
naked Place yeah you need to pee in the
toilet the chairlet and no they're like
are you sure like if this is like a
thing because they're just used to just
doing whatever they want wherever they
want my daughter is a little bit that
way Chili's ass she goes can I go poop
here and I'm like yeah go ahead yeah
there's part of me that's like look the
poop times the poop on the lawn times I
actually have a this is gonna sound fake
I have a fond memory of taking a poop on
the lawn once and I was just like that's
it man talk about Liberty and here at
this house it was earlier today but it
was a very fond memory you know as like
a little as a little kid who I called
myself the Naked Cowboy and I'd wear my
gun belts but nothing else sure
and a log on the lawn
um so we're almost done I know you're
probably doing a lot of press why don't
we talk explicitly about uh the new I
don't have to be anywhere until five
okay yeah well just hit let's let's
still let's talk about the the new book
uh discipline is Destiny Destiny because
so courage is calling is the first one
because the cardinal virtues are courage
Temperance Justice wisdom and Temperance
is
I decided to write about discipline
because I think Temperance one just as a
concept it seems somewhat limiting but
two what they meant by Temperance was
like marks through this in meditations
says discipline more often than says
Temperance because I think Temperance is
like what's the right amount of a thing
which is important you have to know what
the right amount of a thing is but like
I know what the right amount of things
are that's the easy part yeah it's like
doing them is the hard part right that's
what requires my doctor just was like
you you I did a brain scan there like
you should exercise cardio 45 minutes or
five times a week that's what your brain
scan that you need more cardio yeah
because they this shot with Katie and I
were just talking about this I got my
brain scan for ADHD that your brain is
fat was that your brain is fat
actually your brain is mostly fat that's
just that's just true I'm saying you
have an overweight brain they're like
you just need to exercise hilarious I
would like to see you get that down yeah
but the part of my brain that is
depressed like they were like this is
this part that would light up if you
were depressed and I'm not depressed or
I should say I don't experience
depression yeah but they're like looking
at your brain you the area that is
associated with depression is like
really lit up they're like to Ward that
off you should exercise they said 45
minutes five times a week cardio and
then they said this I thought was very
interesting that Prozac and exercise
five times a week are uh
indistinguishable chemically isn't that
interesting you have a pool at your
place in Ohio we do have a pool are you
a swim swim I I think we're just talking
about this swimming is I think the
especially if you're not someone that
likes exercise I think is the most
magical form of exercise tell me
everything no screens
yes they're like if you've ever been in
a like a sensory deprivation tank of
course swimming is a version of that I
mean there's more senses are going on
but like you're weightless you're
weightless you can't hear you you're
seeing you can only see like directly in
front of you because of how you're
looking
and you're you just get in this Zone I
think it's very magical yeah and how
because I just sent myself an email I'll
show you not that you don't believe me
but I wrote just try swimming with a
timer because I don't like counting laps
I find that money so if you get an Apple
Watch that's what she said you can pick
the length I actually I it I've I used
to swim but the the part of my brain
that was thinking about counting laps
and then did I mess up did I cut myself
short am I that was too much that this
you just check every once in a while and
you're like oh okay I've done I've got
15 more laps or whatever I like that a
lot counts the laps it counts the laps
for you if the only flaw is it does not
count kickboard laps she just said this
oh it does wow that's huge yeah it it
steals your kickboard laps which is the
only you're only doing the exercise for
the fake uh digital points anyway
obviously we were just talking about
this yeah that's so funny literally the
same conversation but you find it to be
because I gotta do it it's like a long
pool so you could get like a satisfying
yeah the pool at my house is like the
most personal it's only nine yards and
so like it
it's too much but it's swimming is the
best yeah okay I'm definitely gonna give
it a whirl
um where were we exercise
do you remember oh brain scan yeah
depression about why you need to
exercise that's why I need to exercise
and then we're talking about discipline
or something I don't know yeah so I know
yeah thank you oh yeah knowing what you
should know and then doing it I know
that's what I'm supposed to do but how
am I supposed to do that yeah exactly
for me it's usually the opposite it's
like I love to run and swim and I I want
to do some form of strenuous exercise
every day if I'm like not feeling well
or if I'm tired or if like I haven't
eaten or whatever it's harder for me to
be like that is a bad idea you should
rest today like the load management
thing oh all the chatterstone books are
almost always mostly I'm talking about
myself but yeah like to not do it
because it's a bad idea and that uh if
the restraint to be like hey I'm gonna
do this this way that's harder for me
but I'm the opposite it seems like a
humble brag though like my thing is I
just work too hard yeah exactly but I'm
a perfectionist yeah I just care so much
knowing when to go home that's my
biggest ball like it's hard I lose track
of time just getting a flow State
working here no I think you would like
swimming though it's it's very magical
and it's like super good exercise also
but it's and good mental health clearly
yes and you don't get sore Katie just
told me you don't get sore when you swim
oh you get sore no not really
um no it's it's really good and then it
it
I get it's it's meditative too because
like you're just there's there's you're
not like on a run you're like oh what's
that where am I you're just like you it
forces you to zone out very quickly
that's why I'm thinking if I do it with
a timer sorry if this is a snooze
everybody but it's almost done doing
with a timer and not counting because I
don't like counting laps I'm going like
one two three it brings a the other side
of my brain and to be honest but if
there's just a timer going
absolutely love it that in uh cold
therapy which everybody knows yes I was
gonna thank you I got uh that coal
plunge you did they sent me one and uh I
I've only used it like four or five
times because it just came but uh I love
it isn't it amazing yeah it totally
shocks it's it's so like
you're talking about being present it
forces you to be present that's what I
call it yes forced meditation yeah you
can't do it yeah sorry Katie I'm so
embarrassing I get all lit up about this
but you can't do it if you're not
present yeah and you can't do it if not
only do you have to be present but you
have to be positive president meaning
you have to you have to remember to
smile you have to hold the word yes in
your mind all of this stuff and that's
how you started your day like come on
right because if you're sitting in there
and you're like this is awful this is
awful this is awful or you'll get out or
it just makes the time go slower it's
the worst so you have to be like
exactly right where you are
um what was I going to tell you the
other what's the company it's plunge
yeah it's thecoldplunge.com slash weird
I believe for a or a weirdo checkout
um yeah I absolutely love that shocking
the system overriding it resetting your
day too is another big reason why I do
it but anyway before I do a talk now
that the co-pound I'll do it before I do
a talk like culture I do the shower like
the last part of it to me it's like the
one it's the like I'm in charge yeah the
cranking it yeah and then it's the you
just feel different when you step out of
it that's Old Timmy Fair Timmy Ferris
when when I did
um I had to do two weeks alone in an
apartment in Montreal
um for home alone so I was alone I was
alone for two weeks and I I listened to
a lot of Tim Ferriss and and he said
if you don't do a cold shower in the
morning every time I don't know if this
is true but he was like if you do it all
you'll see are solutions and if you
don't do it all you don't see your
problems that's right and he thought
there was something neurological and
physiological to that and and it's what
you're saying it's electing to do
something you don't want to do and
especially in the morning oh this is
what I was going to tell you it's the
best learning curve thing ever meaning
you just got it right so I don't let's
not
um Macho each other but I'm just saying
when I started I started at 60 because
that's as high as it can be until oh 60
degrees 60 degrees okay and then you do
60 and it's brutal then the next age is
60 and it's okay then the third day you
do 60 and it's too warm and you start
lowering it yeah we just moved as you
know and mine is at 13 39 now which is
as low as it goes so the first time I
got in at 39
I got in the water 40 seconds I was out
I had to get out sure like I literally
was like I don't know how I ever did
that next day uh two minutes it was fun
like what I'm saying is if you want the
feeling of getting better at something
cold exposure is like is the way to go
because your body is multiple you can
either crank the temperature or the time
yes and so you have multiple notches to
make it harder or that's right but you
can see exercise that way that's why
people like exercising is that right
yeah you're like how fast did I do the
swim how many laps did I do yeah this is
what this is why weightlifting is so
addicting for people because it's so
numbers based like how many sets yeah
what's my PR but for running it's like
yeah how far did you go yes it's I hear
you that I have we talked I don't think
we have I I just got a tonal do you know
what a tonal is that's the screen the
screen with the arms yeah the screen
with you so I've been doing
weightlifting almost every day now and
I'm telling you Val and I were laughing
I got like a vein in my bicep I'm not
going to show it to you I've never been
a vein bicep guy you have veins in your
bicep don't you you son of a [__] but
anyway I also find myself everybody
knows I'm going to say this but I want
to hear what you have to say upping my
testosterone has the biggest and most
noticeable effect on my personality sure
more than anything more than too much
coffee more than I didn't eat lunch I
become like very like just do it like
decisive and a little bit shorter
tempered and it's all just because of
this Jack and testosterone from lifting
weights have you noticed that uh I
haven't like started doing it yeah you'd
have to just start it yeah this is new
data from yeah but you're shocking the
system and you're feeling the benefits
of so you're and you're old enough to be
able to perceive it and notice it that's
right whereas like if you if just been
doing it since you're a kid you're just
like this is life that's right I feel it
when I don't do it though like I I can
go like only a couple days and then it
feels like everything's falling apart
well that's why I wonder if Tom Brady
they were saying that a lot of athletes
when they retire fall into depression
yeah and it's because they stopped it's
not because they it's the game
necessarily it's because they stopped
exercising because we're back to the
beginning of our conversation what was
their why have when I was doing How We
Roll I was running every morning cold
and and all these things intermittent
fasting just because you had this reason
sure some people because it was the
reason was how I look on camera know how
I feel oh how I feel how I look is is on
there actually those are my reasons on
that poster right there it's it says
Leela
Val
I think that's like live yeah like be
alive oh those are your those are your
sort of ones like hearts oh that's good
heart health is interesting to me like I
really don't want my heart to just be
like it's pretty lucky for you yeah it's
pretty important yeah tell that to like
90 it sounds so obvious but tell that to
everyone I know growing up uh yeah and
look yeah and life look is Vanity sure
yeah so tell me tell me something from
the book that is a little bit in the in
the discipline maybe not a hack but
something that you learned putting it
together that maybe that people would
enjoy when it comes to applying I think
my favorite my favorite story in the
book is
um I got really into Jimmy Carter when I
was writing it and uh there's a story he
he so he goes to the Naval Academy he's
a sort of like uh you know like hot
upstart kid who comes from the small
town in in Georgia and he goes to the
Naval Academy he graduates uh and then
he wants to get in the nuclear submarine
service us which at that time you had to
be interviewed by this guy named Admiral
rickover who was the sort of most
exacting like uh like brilliant guy and
he basically invents the Nuclear Navy
his fascinating character he would
personally interview everyone who would
serve on a nuclear summary so he
interviews uh Carter it's like this
three-hour interview they talk about
everything you know he quizzes them on
literature and physics and Military
strategy and all this stuff and um
he uh he goes so how did you do in the
Naval Academy and he goes
um I was like you know 58th in my class
of 800 or something and he like expects
rickover to be like impressed and
rickover has of course interviewed
everyone probably the other 50 people in
that said class and every class for like
50 years yeah and he goes oh but did you
always do your best and Carter sort of
instinctively is going to be like yeah
of course and then he for some reason he
he like doesn't and he kind of thinks
about it for a second he's like well you
know he's like thinking to himself you
know sometimes like I posted or I didn't
ask for extra credit or I didn't
whatever he goes you know what no I
don't think I always did my best and um
rickover just goes why not and then he
gets up and he leaves the room Jimmy
Carter does no Rick over leaves oh he
says why not cool it was like you know
what [__] you I just left so yeah he
just says why not and then that question
haunts him for the rest of his life
um he's like that if you're gonna do a
thing or you're gonna so to me best and
presence is also similar like why are
you phoning it in why are you thinking
like oh I'll do it half later you know
like and so this question of like did
you always do your best is to me a
really interesting one and I think it it
takes discipline right like if you think
about like if you're good at what you do
you can 70 is often enough right like
you can you could you can half-ass it
you can Coast you you figure like when
I'm writing the book
there's things I know I can do to make
the book easier am I going to do that or
am I going to you know what I'm saying
like there's writing the book easier
yeah or or I'm like I'm sure on stage
there's things there's easy laughs you
know you can do or are you gonna but is
that like actually like hard for you
right you know what I mean yeah so I
don't know I think the idea of like I'm
I'm always going to show up I'm always
going to do my best I don't know that
was a story that stuck with me like
thinking through the book it was really
interesting and then I've just become
totally fascinated with him as a person
I wonder yeah he's supposed to be a
sweetheart too
um that's my contribution you're
supposed to be real nice sweet as a
lollipop I wonder what what is the
Intolerable feeling of doing your best
is it the vulnerability that maybe
you'll do your best and fail yeah
because Ernest they're Being Earnest is
the vulnerable because then if you care
and then someone else says like you suck
or doesn't like it or what if your best
is not good enough yeah right what it so
if you did your best and you were first
in your class that's worked out for you
yeah what if you did your best and then
your 50th in your class yeah like you're
there's 49 people better than you yeah
but so you have to decide like what race
are you running like are you running a
race against everyone else or are you
running a race against yourself and then
so I I think I think it's the
vulnerability of it for sure it's it's
ah
I remember Robert Greene actually said
this to me once he was saying that
teenagers are like
simultaneously rebellious and
lackadaisical so you're like oh it
doesn't matter I don't care about that
so then you don't have to try and
because if you're like follow the
instructions stick with the thing and
then try and then it doesn't work out
that challenges your sense of who you
are I think that's really hard so to me
but it's it's scary to like I I think
and generationally like this is why
irony and stuff are so popular because
it's a defense Shield against like
who did you read that New York Times
piece I I never watched succession but
who's like the who's the main character
have you watch the session
no no the the one that the one that
people don't like
um
Kendall
Kendall Roy yes that method actor yes
yes and that that piece that was like
basically like sort of sub making fun of
him for like actually caring about his
work wow you know what I mean yeah
they're like what a douche like this guy
like cares as opposed to a lot of modern
stars that so much of their appeal I
would say like Bo Burnham is like the
glaring example the antithesis of this
like he cares yeah he's doing it he's
running his he's racing himself so
clearly but Bo and I actually talk about
this a lot of people his age the not
just the wrapping paper the product
itself is I don't care yeah and people
are like drawn to that because
earnestness
I'm sure you've heard this but The
Importance of Being Earnest Oscar
Wilde's play everyone was naming their
child Earnest and the quality of
earnestness was so ubiquitous that he
was satirizing how we had become
obsessed with earnestness yeah but here
we are like the opposite of obsessed
with earnestness like Mr Rogers seems so
yeah extra in his cringe yeah he is to
be like what if we were well we even
have all these words extra cringe extra
and cringe are both yeah rebellions
against earnestness and you're
absolutely right the guy what is the guy
who played Kendall
Jeremy Strong people were so mad at him
because he was he was giving a [__] yeah
I remember hearing those stories that
he's in a at some point he's he's dunked
in water let's just say that and and uh
for those scenes he would pour ice cold
water on himself not for a cold one but
because he was method and that got
written up as like what a sports nut or
like what a knot yeah and it's like no
it worked he did a good job well there's
uh the internet expression is like low
nothing matters you know like but to to
be like no like I care like this is
important even though existentially it
doesn't you know like he's like but to
to actually like care is I think it's
it's hard and it's scary and then to try
and then to to try and then both care
and not care about the results that's
like that's the attention I think I
agree and what we're talking about
sounds conceptual but it really is a
feeling too the feeling
of trying your best
or putting yourself out there I've told
this story a million times but Ted
Danson was on a show and he does a Scene
It would be like if we were talking and
then I'd go over to Katie and I'm just
like
and then I come back to you and he goes
isn't acting embarrassing and I was like
oh my God that's the job yeah the money
or whatever or what you're being hired
to do is to be talking to a sound guy
yeah about living in Ojai yeah and then
go
like that is so embarrassing yeah it's
actually kind of like sociopathic like
I'm gonna go over there and cry now
that's what the money is for it's get
over you're probably to speak places get
over the weirdness yeah that you're
being exalted as like a special person
or you're writing books get over the
weirdness of saying you should actually
hear my thoughts well I've had to like
because writing is I think the more
introverted of all the sort of
entertainment related things and I
wouldn't say it's the most glamorous but
it's the least like having to put
yourself out there so it's kind of
mythologized as it's like you know it's
like Hemingway The Typewriter with a
cigarette like it's just it's cool
because there's it doesn't seem like
you're exerting yourself it's also done
it's like I'm not gonna change and be
like oh I actually meant I did like I
just mean the act of doing it or doing
it like to go ahead and sing or dance
those are like that's probably the most
like put yourself out there of the
things yeah yeah right whereas like
writing is like just typing and sitting
there yes
um and uh and so like you don't you
don't have to do that if you don't want
to and like watching now you we exist in
a world where social media is how people
find out about things and so to like
have to like
like for a daily joke we do like I do
like a tick tock and a Instagram reel
like every day that I have to like sit
in front of a camera and record which is
the opposite of writing right and it's
like but and there's a cringness to it
but then it's also like if I care about
this thing and I want people to hear
about it yeah I have to think about the
medium that they're likely to hear about
that thing in and that requires Tick
Tock no yes but before to to do that it
requires you to be like
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna put I'm gonna
actually I'm gonna take myself out of
the very safe like no risk Universe
which is sitting and writing and do this
other thing
um
have you heard of the millennial pause
do you know what this the millennial
pause is like anyone over a certain age
when you like sit start to record you
like you hit record and then you wait
for a second because like that's like
how we've sort of grown up and like
younger people just like start
in the millennial pause is like a very
reveal it like reveals how old you are
like what do you hear recording you go
hello yes yes oh my God I had a
camcorder that it was a feature yeah was
it would wait three seconds it hit
record
and then gave you time to run into the
shot so that's the Gen X pause yeah it's
a longer pause yeah yeah yeah the
millennial pause let's just in closing
here because I loved it I know it's in
the intro to the book so it's kind of
obvious maybe for me or maybe it's
cringe or extra but like I loved and got
a lot out of
um the the Hercules story and maybe we
could talk about that because there's
there's a lot of because you know at the
end of the show we talk about we've been
talking about it the whole time
religion and spirit and all that sort of
stuff I think there's something
essential to the origins of the universe
and the meaning of life in this story so
that's why I saved it for here well
weirdly that's also the founding story
of stoicism which is that Zeno is this
successful Merchant he suffers this
shipwreck he washes up in Athens he has
nothing and he walks to a bookstore like
2300 years ago their bookstores he walks
into this bookstore and the owner of the
bookstore is reading uh xenophan uh but
he's reading xenophen is just xenophen
and Plato are the two people who write
socrates's stories and he's reading
Socrates
telling the story of the choice of
Hercules no way yes you know goes to him
and he says where can I find someone
like that and that is what starts him on
his journey towards philosophy wow but
the choice of Hercules is the story is
Hercules as this young man it's walking
through the hills of Greece and he comes
to this Crossroads the the road diverges
like the Robert Frost poem and you're
looking familiar
Bobby Frost you didn't read this at your
dentist's office on a poster it was
right there too oh man why did I choose
the path where I made a cleaning
appointment he he uh he can choose
between two paths but at each one
there's a goddess and one goddess
promises him everything he wants in a
life of ease and pleasure and and all
the sort of soft things in life and the
other says this will be a harder path
and it'll challenge you more and there
will be risks and this is sacrifice
sacrifice and and yeah and and all the
virtues like cons you know restraint and
self-discipline and courage and it's
it's you can have everything you want
even work for it you know what which
you're going to choose and he famously
chooses uh the path of virtue that this
is this so the Herculean Crossroads or
the choice of Hercules is that and I
think even to go over like the choice to
do your best or not do your best like
that it's all this sort of Herculean
it's all those Crossroads moments like
where you what are you gonna do the hard
thing or the easy thing and or The Road
Less Traveled or you know the road well
traveled like uh it makes all the
difference right which one are you going
to choose not familiar yeah uh it's
interesting where I went with that too
is that isn't that let let's
anthropomorphize and say there is a God
and it's like you and I it's a it's a
mind and a body and it's floating in
Infinity
didn't God choose the second path too
you know what I mean when I was little I
was like If Heaven I I don't believe
this is the case anymore but there's
heaven and Hal and what you do
determines where you go
um if that's true and God loves us why
why not just start in heaven like why
not just birth Souls into Paradise
that's kind of what that question is
saying this is why I'm drawn to a lot of
there's a lot of music and surprisingly
a lot of it is pop music
um that I find very edifying there's a
song on The Sing 2 soundtrack where she
goes
I want to feel love and pain I want to
feel pride and shame this is probably
like a huge pop song and everyone's
laughing at how cringe and extra I'm
being right now but I'm just saying like
by earnestly saying that you like a song
from my children's book probably not yes
but it's also a pop song what I'm saying
is the embarrassment is if it's Shakira
or something and everyone's like how do
you not know that but it's like I'm
really drawn to music like that that
talks about our either unconscious that
we can make conscious but our desire we
want to feel shame we want to feel pain
we want to do it wrong we don't in the
moment but like we were saying we look
back and we go it was the delayed flight
that was the story but my point is god
let's let's presuppose a God or imagine
a God that could do anything and could
have like the Matrix created a reality
where everything is soft and easy
clearly that if this if this God exists
didn't choose that it shows the one
where [__] up [__] is constantly
happening kind of like Hercules chose
I'll take the [__] up path well
certainly Jesus picks the harder path
right like he could have just eaten an
apple and said like all your sins are
forgiven yes he was like no I'll do the
crucifixion option he did yeah right he
could have kept his mouth shut yeah he I
mean I'm not even trying to be funny
it's like he was tick-tocking it he's
like I gotta go to yeah
yeah but I mean like what a pain in the
ass there's also meeting people where
they were constantly
imagine being a realized being and you
have to be like
by the way I realize being 2 000 years
ago and someone's like no teeth and a
bird is eating one of their eyes what
should we do and you have to be like
um it's sort of like a lost coin you
know like you could have just said what
he [__] meant instead he used to tell
them what I'm saying is these people
were mostly illiterate he was probably
illiterate like there wasn't like a lot
of resources going around so you're like
Jesus's stories are very simple and
there's a reason because the people he
was talking to some of them were on fire
you know like literally Ablaze I think
go into the do your best thing I I also
think that's what the parable of the
talents is about
right like you sort of have these gifts
or you'll be given this thing do you
increase it do you make it into a thing
the three servants are given towns by
their Master One buries them I always
relate to that guy yeah the scared guy
it's kind of not a it should be they eat
all three of them do something different
but it's like one buries them and then
one the other two one gets some money
and then the other gets like a lot of
money out of it it's not not a perfect
story I'm sure it ends with him beating
the guy yeah and also they're not
servants they're obviously slaves uh
yeah but um
let's just change the name and then we
want to think about it honestly I think
there there's a possible like a 5 000
years in the future and they're like
yeah they were they were cutting cow's
heads off and eating their flesh like
there's like barbaric things going on
because yeah no I'm not I'm not giving a
pass at all [__] up [__] [__] up um
but anyways I think the idea is that you
have these I think it's it's a wonderful
sort of uh fortuitous circumstance that
Talent a unit of money then
is also how we now think of like right
skill yeah and so it's like you you've
been given this talent and what do you
do with it you know do you take the easy
way and sort of Coast on it or do you
like make it what it is meant to be it's
interesting I you know there's different
altitudes I think that Jesus is teaching
on that seems like a practical that's a
Tim Ferriss that's a life hack you know
what I mean he's like you have this
opportunity use it spend it risk it
right but then he my favorite of of
Jesus's stories are the ones we're like
uh he hires three people to work in
their fields again maybe but one of them
shows up at 8am there's a there's a
paraphrase one of them shows up but
Aiden works all day one that shows up at
10 and works all day one of them shows
up at like 9 00 p.m and works for 20
minutes and they all get paid the same
those are the ones that I'm like that
feels like the highest altitude he's not
telling you how to live your life he's
telling you that you're loved no matter
what the weird thing for me is I am
fascinated Jesus and I've read about him
quite a bit but and then I'm like you
know Seneca was alive at the same time
just saying what he [__] meant like
living in a house like they're what like
it was also this sort of mystical
nonsense for like no reason like we
actually just yeah like he didn't have
to be so esoteric well just like people
read the Bible and they're like oh this
is it was so long ago and it's like
there were like normal people doing
normal things at that time like like you
know Senator was a job then and now you
know like like this wasn't there's works
of literature that aren't esoteric yeah
that are very clear yeah and the people
had like I mean normal-ish names and no
they'd you're never reading like a story
about some Roman and they're like and he
lived to be 432 years old and had 18
children and right you know like right
like there were non-crazy people then
like it's not that's hilarious like it
wasn't all goofy goof seneca's brother
is in the Bible wow he's a guyo he lets
Saint Paul go whoa crazy yeah and so
yeah like we the Bible is this weird
kind of my it's like hearing voices and
there's all this stuff but in the same
note what I just watched uh the last
duel yeah and I was like this is like a
thousand years after Jesus yeah or more
yeah it's roughly like 1200 really
someone around there and I'm like
they're still like brushing their teeth
with a rat and I'm like yeah the fact
that a thousand years
the argument is that Rome is the like
sort of a pop theosis of civilization
and Christianity takes us here and then
oh is that what it is then the
Enlightenment and the Renaissance come
out here oh so it was here yeah and then
we go down here and we're brushing with
rats and yeah fighting Adam Driver in a
college it's like the pope putting you
know like a like a cow on trial for like
you know tempting someone into [__]
it and stuff like this is like the this
is the Ridiculousness of the Dark Ages
yeah yes okay
like like the things that the Romans had
like that that then the Dark Ages were
like oh yeah we don't know how to do
that anymore it's like it's because you
burned all their [__] books and stuff
one of the craziest control out deletes
of our history like you know what yeah
let's close and let's delete these
programs you know my favorite Jesus meme
is uh he walks into he's like Jesus
walks into a restaurant and they go like
we we wanna
we're on a table for 24. and she goes
there's only 12 of you and he says
we're all going to sit on the same side
that is a table for 24. that's very good
that's very good mine is it's the Earth
and then it zooms out to the solar
system and as far out as we've gone
there's a giant Jesus and he's saying
don't Master but
[Laughter]
chill insights before we go uh what a
weird question I'm just as I was saying
that I was like my belief just to load
you with something so it's not just a
bald question
my belief is the further out you go
you're not really going anywhere meaning
that it's all in here as well you know
what I mean it's like when people look
at the new satellite photos and I'm like
doesn't that make you feel insignificant
and I've tried to express this before
and and I don't know how well of a job I
did but it's like anything out there is
also here meaning it's all the same
thing if it's all written on
if I'm the paper it's all written on
deep down Consciousness it doesn't
matter how far up down left or right we
go it's all one phenomenon well it's
like looking at some crazy thing from
outer space it's not that is
incomprehensibly vast and you know all
the stuff and it's not really any more
incomprehensible than like the back of
your hand that's exactly what I'm saying
like it's easier to go like whoa yeah
imagine how many players that is it's
like
how did you hear the thought whoa
imagine how many planets that is like
that and I say this every time I say
this but like why do you have to be
stoned for that to be interesting how
can you hear your thoughts how can you
you put this together and it just
becomes normal that my body's here
because I know if I touch this I don't
feel it but I touch this and I feel it
but like we see with our kids like
they're in the soup like they're they're
seeing this for as amazing as it is well
economists talk about this too Adam
Smith it was actually Adam Smith's
Wealth of Nations and then he writes
this book called the theory of moral
sentiments which is sort of based on
stoicism a couple other philosophicals
but like it's also a miracle that like
if you go to the store right now and you
want milk this is the example they use
other people don't drink milk anymore
but you're like how do they eat milk how
do they know you want it and how do they
have it there and how did it get there
it's [__]
incomprehensible like the data that went
into that just all of it just like the
that you decided right now how to want
something and then you can go to a place
that you didn't tell you wanted it and
they knew you wanted it and had it there
just in time even though it expired like
yeah all of the uncoordinated magic and
wisdom and human interactions and things
that had to go right for that to occur
is like very remarkable and that's like
such an utterly ordinary thing that's
right and then then you're like okay how
some immense like the invention of a
vaccine or you know like the the some
massively coordinated human thing that's
that's even more impressive but just
like passively just like most of the
stuff you want whatever you want is
there and that is not a historical yeah
it's constant it's where yeah that's
right that's interesting I what helped
me as I was thinking about what you're
saying is that's sort of the magic of
the movies is when I tell you a story
how amazing is it that I or someone
wrote a story and we both watch it and
we're like moved to tears or whatever
like we both watch Moonlight and we're
like you know that's also a miracle but
we're like I went to the movies it's
like no someone's complaining that the
ticket was however much exactly the
popcorn was like a little expensive
right yeah but what a miracle that
that's a miracle it's all it's all
insane this sort of goes back to what
you were saying it's like to me
motivating yourself with fear or ego or
desperation or a rivalry is there's a
parallel to being like needing the
universe to be like
categorically like data based this is
how vast it is this is how deep it is
this is the rate at which it's expanding
you tell me how fast we're spinning and
how fast we're going like I don't I
don't care like I don't need that that
to me seems like the sweatier version of
going like or you could just sit in a
chair and go like what the [__] am I
yeah it's so close I'm not sad by the
way it sounds like I'm anti-space
exploration I'm just saying I don't have
to go that far to be like in fact I
don't know if it's helpful to go that
far it's all magical right yeah and it
starts with you so go go go to the
closest thing where like you know each
person is you know has a totally unique
set of DNA that's never existed before
ever in human history then you add you
layer on top of that the moment that
they're born the experiences that like
every part of you has never existed ever
before the rarest comic book there's
ever been and yet also like I saw this
New York Times piece about it there's
probably someone that looks like exactly
like you walking the Earth also at the
same time it's just like insane yeah
yeah that's right because it's funny
being an a public person
someone's gonna say figure take it easy
um but a public person people will send
me hey I'm in Sweden look at this guy
and I'm like oh my God it's me yeah
[__] crazy it is weird yeah super
precious I I love all of these thought
experiments and I I always enjoy talking
with you is there anything that we
didn't cover I don't think so I didn't I
don't have an agenda you have an agenda
you have an alt-right agenda yes and I
have the best I've known this about you
for a very long time
um well thanks
by the way your interview with Robert
Greene was so good wasn't it great thank
you did you like it it's so good that
means a lot because it was in my mind I
was like I hope Ryan likes this I hope
someone touched you even listen to it's
so good he was awesome he's the best not
I think I told this again not what I was
expecting the guy that's like 48 Laws of
Power and he comes in and you're like
Yoda you know what I mean yeah you
expect like a bro I thought I'd have
Oakleys on the back of his head really
yeah a little bit just based on the
title than I did any research and I knew
it wasn't going to be that way
but you know I had that with Father Greg
Boyle the founder of Homeboy Industries
you know the gang orientation brilliant
the whole time I was picturing like I
think it was like he would be ex-gang is
he no oh he looks like Santa Claus
interesting he's a he's a Santa Claus
figure that's a great Episode by the way
I really would enjoy that and if you
have guests on your podcast he would be
great yeah yeah anyway all right can you
think of a I probably this is the third
time you've done the show so I'd
probably asked you this three times so
feel free to pass but can you think of a
time in your life when you laughed
really really really really hard yeah I
think I told the kid one last time but I
have a different one that I was thinking
of we were uh
we were at this pool and we'd gotten
like food delivered so we're sitting
outside eating and um my son walked up
to me and he goes is this the dead bird
you were talking about and then he was
holding a dead bird that he found
and I think about it all the time we
talk about all of that because none of
it makes any sense at all where did he
get the dead bird he didn't kill the
dead bird like he found a dead bird he
was like I found it right here but it
was like I hadn't you were what Denver
was I talking about and it just so what
was happening in his head where he goes
ah this is the did he make it up you
know it's just magic I
I am dead and I it's just it's so the
essence of parenting and now that Lila's
almost four we're just get we have a
shared file in our phone and we just
write him down they'll never be as
precious to anyone else is there to me
but that one I think anyone can get that
one is this the Ted bird you were
talking about
what and what do you what do you think
would happen yes but yeah it's you know
like it's just when you see them doing
what we do which is continuing conver
I'm not saying your son is I think we
all do this confusing reality with inner
reality yes and dreams and I see Leela
do this with TV I do it with TV now that
I'm older I'm seeing a deterioration
where I'm like but aren't you
the guy who cooks meth yeah you know
like in his Winnebago not really but
like little have you heard them say like
smash that subscribe button like things
that they've heard on YouTube that's the
best oh no yes
all right just leave a link in the
comment or like I'll leave a link in the
comments below they'll just say things
hilarious yes it's the best it's also it
also makes you feel like a horrible
parent because you're like oh you're
watching too much but it's also
hilarious well I we're staying away from
YouTube as long as we can no judgment
that's not but because I don't want to
leave my daughter with a iPad and 45
minutes she's a flat earther she's just
like right wake up sheeple wait how did
you said wake up sheeple to me
right I really I think you're just the
juice man you're super cool and I love
talking with you and it's I mean you're
in I'm just trying to give you a
compliment and be like not a lot of
people have done the show three times
and not a lot of people have done the
show three times and every time I've
never worried about what we're gonna
talk about like I've enjoyed reading
your new book getting ready but like I'm
not like what are we gonna say so you're
the best well thank you would you give
us your third but first on camera keep
it crispy yeah keep it crispy
without hesitation thank you so much man
oh yeah
[Music]